in
five
four
three
two
welcome welcome
you're listening i'm out of the basement
for two hours
[Applause]
i'm losing my mind
i've been locked in this is my fourth
day
in the basement and i'm starting to get
a little bit uh
it's weird it's just weird but i'm out
now
join of course by the council
of uh
eight-year-olds
maybe in the middle like jesus
uh ed jesus a b in the middle there look
how [ __ ] cursed ian is that yeah ian
that's not we don't like that
it's not working
let's analyze so you guys all got the
kid filter uh love continues to be the
cutest undefeated
oh thank you
baby is uh baby baby is uh pretty
adorable too yeah a baby is a baby a
baby is looking very cute say something
say the darndest thing right now baby
no
i was trying to
he's pouting by the way don't move your
head too fast otherwise your beard shows
google gaga oh my god he was eating some
spaghetti earlier with the baby filter
on the funniest [ __ ] i'm spaghetti yeah
i mean my spaghetti
cam you look pretty
cute hey thank you very much your smile
is is uh adorable sparkling just
sparkling i'm just saying that works
zach you have a baby filter on right now
because it's not working
you're funny you are a funny guy
no i'm not making a joke it doesn't look
like it's working very okay there maybe
the hair in your face
wow i'm closer i have to say zach
being a being a kid doesn't exactly suit
you that's an ugly kid right there
who my parents said to him
and uh ian is just a fever dream that's
just he looks like an elden red boss
yeah you look like a uh
[Applause]
[Music]
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofresh and masterclass
love them
got a lot to talk about today but before
we do i have to give a huge shout out to
my wife
uh hilda hill known as hilda
i guess that's it what else
just hilda you look line he looks like
she's something ld oh he'll do this
guys elton john huge collaboration
with the legendary iconic man himself at
teddyfresh.com
[Music]
this one's crazy the sink the sequin
jacket
sick
it's damn yeah it's it's sick super nice
uh you got the hoodie the elton john
it's you really got to see the close-up
because the stitching is all like gold
looks really good i should be wearing it
i don't know why i'm not
i wore a sweater but it ended up being a
small for ela and i do not look good and
small folks
oh
rolled out it's sold out
oh man
yeah this is probably the in my opinion
the coolest piece
um but there's lots of other cool ones
and you said
serelton himself uh
gave the stamp of approval on all this
yes sir
yeah he loves it he thought it was
awesome
well people really mess with the green
one this one's really cool too very
beautiful these are all like uh
embroidered
came out beautiful
there's a whole collection has checked
though this one's really nice too this
one's still oh this one's sold out too
what the hell
wow okay ellen john's doing good
that's nice
but there's a few other ones like this
shirt's awesome
this one's all of your 3xl
this one's good
but besides that there's there's still
stuff go check it out but
um check out this stuff that i haven't
really plugged
polar fleece jacket
it's so nice dude
uh so beautiful
another piece i love is this patchwork
sweater look at that so sick i gotta
wear that next time
[Music]
crazy good
i like the blue one
yeah take it you can have whatever you
wear teddy fresh stand up you're wearing
the the sweater the ellen john one
there's still those in inventory
[Music]
love too
wait what'd you change your face to now
love you look like it's just a different
person
i don't know what you're talking about
are you tom cruise
maybe
love has tom cruise filter on
yeah
anyway guys please
head on over
to teddyfish.com and see if there's
something
that you like there
with peace and love
always
all right
let's see
wait the quartering made a video titled
black folks really do be liking
watermelon and chicken
it was an old clip of his
uh someone posted on our subreddit and
he said it like that
yep
wow and he says there's a reason why
there's no popeyes in the suburbs
i like chick i like chicken and
watermelon i love chip fried chicken
watermelon i mean
that shit's funny doesn't everybody had
stereotypes about yourself
like i i really don't know
like
it i mean
black folks really do be liking
watermelon and chicken
i mean why is that a harmful stereotype
bro there's a reason he's such a [ __ ]
chicken
is it
hey hey love what if you what have you
been going and eating every day
uh coupons yeah
is it you long turn now turns out
everybody likes popeye's chicken because
it's slaps
suburbs
so i but so what who cares i love
chicken why are you saying it
why are you saying it doesn't even
matter then why are you saying it
you're such an idiot
but why is he gonna say like they really
do be liking like he's saying it like oh
yeah they really do be liking it
he's such a [ __ ] dumbass
such a weirdo why you gotta why you
always gotta be such a freak
um
oh abe you wanna do this shtick
apparently we fell below three million
subscribers i don't know if anyone's
following this but we've been steadily
losing subscribers here on the h3
podcast channel
um
ab has been pushing me to
beg you guys beg you guys just please
subscribe
you know just a little like and
subscribe every other podcast does it
every other creator i mean i know
you guys have never done it you and ila
are
are too cool too humble but i think it's
time yeah absolutely you think i need to
start begging oh yeah you don't got a
bag you just you know
i'm not saying like a full like jimmy
kimmel like hey do you like that video
you're like subscribe
hey guys if you like that head on over
to our youtube
subscribe and hit the bell button so you
don't miss a notification my theory is
like um
on youtube know the drill they know to
subscribe they know to hit the bell
every other creator is doing the
propaganda for me you know but maybe new
people don't know we've got to remind
them dude they forget when they watch a
long
dude pewdiepie and his setup tour his
recent setup tour uh he said he said it
like 10 times at the end i mean he was
joking that's the thing we got him we
got a meme well you joke but it's
serious it's very serious so wait what
you want me to say i'll say it every
episode oh yeah that would be great go
ahead absolutely
i don't have to be shameless
turn on all notifications
subscribe
what is this music that keeps playing
this is the inspire inspiration hour
oh cliche music
oh i see i see
this this is making me think of eldon
ring everything is it's the round table
oh yeah
i don't want to start talking about
elder rink too much because
i don't think anyone cares
for hours
but yeah a new video game came out in
ring that everyone's been waiting
apparently the reviews are insane and
based on my uh play through it's the
best it is the best game ever
i've been uh enjoying it quite a bit as
well i only got to play for i don't know
like three hours last night uh
but um it's a lot
yeah i know as i was saying i was like
only three hours
um but yeah i've been enjoying the hell
out of it and then i got to the first
like real boss the one that i was
talking about yeah i uh took me a while
but i yeah i got him i i did like three
attempts on him and uh
was like it's time for bed i'm too tired
so i needed my first boss
and there's like three mini bosses in
the first area that just keep kicking my
ass dude
i think that's intentional i think
you're supposed to like go back yeah no
i well i figured okay i beat this boss
and i'll go back and try them but
they're still too strong
[Music]
yeah i love it though
well i hate it
if you don't know how to play the game
this has got to be the most unforgiving
one because i feel like they give you
tools to make you more strong
they give you the pets and all that cool
stuff in the horse so like they give you
more tools to be stronger but if you
don't know how to play souls games it is
you will get absolutely
wow but that's because it wouldn't play
right get [ __ ] good love because uh
rage quit
you did where did you ragequit how deep
in
like the the second mini boss because
there's like a dungeon with those
jumping things and like a fire
it's like a bunch of fire and [ __ ] i
couldn't get past that
so i honestly the thing is because it's
open world he might have had a
difference yeah i don't know where you
went i i don't without saying too much
because i didn't want to spoil it for
you ethan but i did
fall into a trap like 10 minutes into
the game that teleported me to one of
the hardest areas of the game
oh
like 10 minutes in
and luckily like you said luckily i've
played these games before so i kind of
like knew how to get out of it and
eventually it's so unforgiving but yeah
these games [ __ ] you up i told ap i'll
give him 100 bucks if he beats the first
boss 100 bucks
sure i don't got the game but i'll
download it and i'll uh get reimbursed
so i'll be in the boss
yeah right now it's actually eight it
was 80 bucks they up they raised the
price on it you got suckered by the
deluxe edition my bro
what the hell
all right i'm gonna download it this
weekend i'll pay well anyone that wants
to play i'll pay for it and if you could
beat the first boss i'll give you a
hundred bucks ian you're exclusive you
heard that uh everybody that's watching
ethan will pay you one hundred dollars
by the way ian are you enjoying it
because i know you're a soul's fanatic
right
uh i actually haven't tried it yet i i
i was getting roasted before the show
because i kind of did the boomer thing
and i reserved a physical copy what
physical media in
the year is 2022 and ian is out here
getting physical media
and so when does it arrive oh i
i went i got a notification too which
this proves how it's a waste of time
they go your item is ready for pickup i
went at nine o'clock the store didn't
open until eleven oh he didn't told me
to come so
and i'm why don't you download it i'll
i'm gonna pay for it you download it
return the disk okay i'll send you the
money
i want you to be happy
he's a boomer look at that face
dude those filters are crazy good
anyone else want to take up the
challenge i'll give it a shot cam
i got a show why not i've never played
yeah i'm going to buy you guys all elden
ring i love this game and i want to talk
to all you guys about it
if hundred bucks is on the line i might
have to reinstall honestly
100 bucks dude
by the way that elon filter is so good
so what we're going to do no that's not
good it's
so
i wish i could do it yeah i wish i could
yeah
oh my god dude
anyway guys it's fun
really fun
let's wrap this [ __ ] up and go play what
do we do exactly
let me get back in the basement bro i
love sleeping on the couch
and i love my dogs man but there's not
enough space for the three of us on that
couch no definitely not and they they
get right up in there
i finally took a shower this morning
because i did i don't want to go up into
the bedroom
but i finally went up there with the
mask on and showered i was i was going
on like four three four days without
showering
wait
i don't have anything down there yeah
there's a shower in the basement yeah i
don't i don't have anything there it's
empty
what am i going to just run water on
myself in no time
no toilet i have a way to just get some
well i i freaked out when i got the news
so i just went straight downstairs all i
brought was my toothbrush and toothpaste
gotcha
feel fresh
yo what by the way so what's the deal
with ukraine because you know obviously
you guys have heard the news but then
the like the market was like way down
and then this morning the market was way
up because apparently china was like
where uh
putin said that he's down to have high
level talks but that doesn't seem to be
actually a thing based on what i'm
reading on twitter now i mean i wouldn't
i wouldn't
watch the markets too closely to
determine what's going on
i mean that changes i mean it is
it is first of all i hate the stock
market it's just it's like disgusting
but debauchery i mean
but like it is interesting how it
responded like it went all the way back
up to where it was and it doesn't even
seem to be true
uh
wasn't it slowly uh declining a lot over
the last several weeks in anticipation
of all this though yes and then also
there was like a five percent loss on
the day when it happened
which was like catastrophic it was
massive it was a fifth
forty percent i think oh no in russia
dude the russian stock market was the
single biggest
loss of a stock market ever lost 40
percent that's that's yeah and they lost
like 30 the weeks prior down with 70
i just can't i just failed to understand
how it's worth it for him like the the
russian economy is going to be so
ruined by this
um vladimir putin but on the good on the
on the plus side um
steven seagal totally is on board
he's out there at the front lines
just taking out ukrainian soldiers with
the flick of his wrist
stopping bullets
yeah it's unfortunate with somebody like
him on their side i think that they're
unstoppable
the ultimate warrior no
they dr he air drops in they're shooting
like anti-air
[ __ ] big-ass bullets at him
he's paratrooping down
he's in his key he's deflecting oh yeah
definitely in his key
the 4xl gee
[Laughter]
they had to make a custom belt for him
because that [ __ ]
the normal ones just don't fit
i led them
[Music]
my favorite thing is all these american
who are like just unironically being
like i support russia because they're a
nationalistic fascist christian uh
uh
fascism
like oh yeah i saw that russia also
threatened sweden and finland today yeah
i was like bro you better chill right
now
uh i thought it would be a mistake
on their part sounds like a threat
yeah i wouldn't want to mess with sweden
or finland
well finland
over anything they [ __ ] them up once
kind of
right
but but sweden and finland are really
stable
strong oh yeah well respected countries
absolutely that that that would be crazy
if they did that they said uh
oh because sweden and finland were
there was a conversation about them
joining nato apparently yeah it's been a
conversation for super well it's weird
how i would say you know
until putin was like yo swedes and finns
don't be joining nato or all or there'll
be consequences like shut up [ __ ] we
gonna ride topless on a horse [ __ ] you
that's a piece
it's weird yeah it is scary but like
[ __ ] him dude yeah [ __ ] that dude
you know putin's one of the richest
people in the world because he's just
such a mafia
criminal
it's speculated that he is yeah
especially he isn't but uh yeah
speculated that he's one of the richest
people in the world
just in his house
no pull it up
he's such an evil guy
he really is
and
actually
it's kind of nice to see but also sad is
that the russian people
from what i can tell are just not in
favor of this war at all
yeah i mean
that's his house what is that is that is
that the new xbox
yeah it's bizarre wait he actually lives
in this
he owns it
i guess his is there
yo where's the on button
it looks crazy the controller must be
huge too
yeah
what the [ __ ] dude
yeah yeah but that's the kind of money
he has he just yeah this is like
multiple multiple multiple names
that's 200 billion uh allegedly
200 billy
yeah
elon's got him beat
do something elon
elon's like actually you know putin uh
he has a point uh you know uh
the ukraine shouldn't be uh joining nato
it's it's a provocation and uh they're
totally justified that's what that's
what elon's thinking
let me pull up since we're talking i
didn't expect to talk about this so soon
but let me pull up uh
all these americans who are unironically
supporting putin
which to me is just
it's just um
it's all it's hard to wrap my brain
around that there's actually
people like this and and it's not just
people i mean this is steve bannon this
is this guy's a huge deal
this was trump's top advisor
at one point he did get kicked out
fairly early on i don't know i i
genuinely don't know how big of a deal
he is in like conservative world anymore
right he's like a trump top propagandist
and fundraiser and like he's behind
he's like a puppet master no uh yeah but
he
he was forced out of the trump
administration at one point and
from what i know he basically just does
this radio show now like he's not
directly involved in politics well also
he was he's the founder of breitbart
right or something yes but he isn't with
that anymore either and that's what i
mean he it seems like he's a little bit
more on
his net worth
oh i'm sure he's worth a lot he's gotta
be rich right
yeah
the other guy that he's talking to is
eric prince who's like should probably
be in jail so what what what's the deal
with eric prince because i saw someone
saying he's a war criminal and i don't
know anything about him
uh
he
founded a mercenary group uh that was uh
contracted by the u.s government is he
black water guy yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
he's the black water guy
he he sold it a long time ago he's not
the owner of it anymore um but he
is a
former
probably still cia asset and uh
uh just generally a bad guy yeah
blackwater was a mercenary group the
army
they're still around they've just
changed their name they're called like
academy now or something we're called
the uh unicorn uh yeah they change it to
something like sunshine and beauty they
they're just like mass murdering freaks
i think now they're xe
they
services
they've gone through a bunch of name
changes yeah so they might be
some other thing now i don't know well
guys uh watch this and tell me what you
think just give me your snap judgment
here this is this is wow and the reason
that putin ain't woke
he is anti-woke the russians people
still know which bathroom to use
they know how many how many genders are
there in russia two okay that's all
sudden that's that's that's not that's
not they don't have the flags they don't
have the pride flags outside on their on
there they don't have boys swimming in
girls
uh college swim meets how backward it's
how embarrassing how savage how medieval
how medieval this is why this whole
thing's a scam it's a total and complete
scam and here's the beauty of that's by
the way have you ever seen a less i i
know i'm not a picture of health but
have you ever seen a
less healthy looking dude than steve
bannon he is
dude looks like unfortunate
he has cancer in every organ
[Laughter]
he's just oozing pus from his pores
oh he's got a picture of jesus behind
him [ __ ] dude
thank you yeah i mean so so he says
it by the way in russia putin literally
says there's no gay people here it's
outlawed to be gay in russia
so that's progress for them
also they hate trans people so much and
i don't know why
i really don't but that's pretense i
guess for supporting him is because he's
not putin
who says
who says
the gate there's no gay people in russia
is uh not woke so that's why we support
him
what do you think about that
i mean it's not surprising and i have i
mean this has been a take for a while uh
yeah a lot of aspects not all but a lot
of aspects of
uh the dominant culture over in russia
is
what
conservatives want here
yeah it's crazy man i mean i keep saying
their interests naturally align
they're white christians you know what i
mean these these guys have more in
common with isis than than liberal
democracies i'm telling you
and the reason that putin ain't woke he
is
there's something cut out though still
no how medieval this is why this whole
thing's a scam it's a total and complete
scam and here's the beauty of that's
wait where is it they said that it was
cut something
putin ain't woke
he is anti-woke the russians people
still know which bathroom to use
they know how many how many genders are
there in russia two okay that's all
sudden that's that's that's not that's
not they don't have the flags they don't
have the pride flags outside on their on
their they don't have boys so what the
[ __ ] this post said that steve bannon
say we should be support okay whatever
oh i wouldn't trust the captions i mean
everybody's going to put their own
[ __ ] spin on it just listen to what
he actually um
there's some really great content coming
out of the uh
oh j this is fun this is great jay
station by the way
friend of the show
guys
he says i align completely with putin's
traditional views and support russia
fully
putin is the greatest leader in the
world
is he for real uh abe you're the you're
the g stationologist here oh he's 100
for real he's 100 absolutely then why
did i mean he should probably try to to
try to migrate to russia don't you think
well he's just a [ __ ] idiot so
yeah
maybe he could have uh
isn't he the guy who did the gay potion
like i feel like you'd be put in jail
for making that video in russia
right so
did not go to chernobyl at 3am
that's what i want to see by the way i
keep seeing about how russians are
taking over chernobyl i'm like
why why do they want chernobyl
well
it is a
fairly close to the capital and i
imagine i i i
we got chernobyl guys believe it or not
i'm not an expert on ukrainian uh geolog
or uh geography but there there is
probably some tactical reason that they
are trying to capture it try to turn it
back on
well it also just might be a matter of
them wanting to secure it so that it
doesn't get hit and [ __ ] irradiate
all of russia because that's
the uh what do you call it the jet
stream goes from west to east so i think
everyone is down with that i think
everybody is benefiting if chernobyl
does not get [ __ ] blown up yes that
would that would be very very that's
good
let's support that i guess thank you dan
by the way this is just to show you guys
i start seeing i've seen some crazy
takes from people online like
eric swalwell right who's a democrat
hate to see it
he goes we need to kick russians out of
university
i was like you dumb [ __ ]
oh god you stupid idiot what's next
internment campaign
camps these the russian people don't
they're not [ __ ] war criminal putin
this is putin
you stupid
[ __ ] what an idiot
yeah so don't blame the russian people i
mean russians are not
they're not to blame for this this is
literally the act of a dictator
this is what's going on in russia right
now by the way just just to show you
you're saying no war
yeah
yeah people marching through central
moscow this evening chanting no to war
those people are extremely brave and
they're all dead now i hope not they're
all in a ditch i really hope not
i don't think they can take care of that
many people they probably just
put them in prison for a little bit
hopefully
i
depends on if they're the organizer or
just a participant or something right
the organizers might be
yeah might be getting
might be getting alive it's scary
but it's not all
uh morons
there's actually some some really great
content
coming for example
of an act oh is that uh
gabe who was that
white club game
it's brucy time
it it's what time
russia tell i took over brucy i'm brucy
now cause i won baby [ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
wait he's so small can i see a bigger
feed cam you have to turn off the
council for me to pin him i'm afraid
yeah hold on i gotta see what you're
brucy what what does that mean
oh that shirt dude that [ __ ] i would
babysit okay
bruce from the longest yard okay yeah uh
dude that shirt is out of control bro
[Laughter]
oh yeah you know i can see through it
right
yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
you look good man you look happy
how what's your how are you following
the news in uh the ukraine right now
well i hope i hope you i hope
that ukraine does better [ __ ] they
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
baby along dude just right
yeah
just
get along and i want i want everybody to
be happy you know just you know yeah
hell yeah i want peace yeah let's go
gabe let's go me too friday baby yeah
first friday baby friday no wars on
friday right yeah is there war on friday
gabe
no
no
friday
friday would be a saturday
a war on saturday no no no
no war at all no war
how's your tick tock does your tick tock
getting any traction
it's um it's getting traction in other
papers it's i'm still i'm still in the
shadow bad restriction
did the piss in my ass thing work for
you at all did i ask you that last week
yeah it is good right it is good it
works good yeah [ __ ] should do you want
if you ever want a new one i can help
you do you want a new one are you good
with pissing my ass for now um let's
let's try a new one okay
how about
um
[ __ ] you could do a [ __ ] on my tits
piss
now we discussed that
we didn't like that one we've eaten that
uh you could say
uh
eat
no no no no no that's that's not chad
feel free to uh chime in with some um
some suggestions here too
how about uh
[ __ ] my tits
that's a good one yeah i like that [ __ ]
my tits just go [ __ ] my tits baby come
on [ __ ] my test baby i think that one's
good [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah we did big dick
energy that did pretty good big dick
energy spit on my tip somebody suggested
spit on my tits yeah spit on my ted
gargle my nards uh
what else we got here it's gotta be
shocking and unexpected puke on my face
ew my ass
that's vulgar
i think uh [ __ ] my tits is funny coming
from you
that's let's try that if they don't if
they don't
give me any community guidelines
violation i'd be okay you know
yeah that might not help if that's the
concern
we might need to think of like a pg
thing for you to say that could help
your tick tock yes
i know tick tock is more like
it's more about community guys anything
about business where people will laugh
get a laugh
right
you know i don't like caves and i don't
know somebody reported on um
bullying and harassment like i harassed
cain
you harassed cain's chicken
it's it's my opinion i don't like their
means
i don't really i'm not crazy about kings
well hold on now you we're our video's
about to get banned for harassment gabe
you better tone it down when you're
talking about kane's chicken
i don't want to get banned for bowling
so well you know what we're going to
think for next week let's try to think
of a pg thing for for gabe to say pg one
yeah because i don't want them to be
shadow bands okay all right but if
there's it do you have one last message
for uh vladimir putin
if you're speaking directly to vladimir
putin what would you say to him
i just hope that family putin will come
to a sense and say oh no
let's get along i just want everybody to
you know be friends you know
get along together work is peace that's
about it that's all i want
no wars no enemies
just weekends
this weekend
we can't just
have fun you know i like to get along
with my my enemies and my foes you know
i feel happy maybe we could air drop
some white claws over the battles
oh yeah
what flavor would you drop
it's either lime or cherry lime or
cherry [ __ ]
all right dude you have a great weekend
okay
thanks for checking in we'll see you
next week thanks gabe
peace
take care buddy you're the best
careful with that by the way
careful showing that for real
yeah all right take care
all right bye-bye all right
take care
all right all right
take care buddy okay
all right
peace
peace there you go
all right we'll see you next week
uh cam you need to uh
remember him
thanks buddy see you next week
it wasn't me this time he watching me
this time
he gave me a little bit of uh
it's just the okay zipper no no i know
but they can't have that but they took
it no
i'm taking it back i'm taking it back
dude that filters are crazy all right
bring back the
council i don't want to see jim carrey
love that close up
what's happening you're moving shuffling
everyone around this is how it works can
you give me an alrighty then love
all right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what
you don't know you don't know what ace
ventura that's effective
i don't know no
dude that movie was made like 20 years
before he was born already then i
thought that was ubiquitous ubiquitous
for people ubiquitous and and for people
our age yeah but for i mean you guys all
know alrighty then right
no i definitely do yeah yeah yeah well
they're all millennials and zach is
like zack's basically a boomer somehow i
am i'm definitely him
so
look how i'm dressed wear this on an
everyday basis
alrighty well anyway well we were gonna
talk about all the celebrities who are
doing good things for ukraine for
example
this uh woman here her name is anne lynn
mccord
she is a actress
so
we're got a bit of a uh
what was the gal gadot thing uh uh
imagine um we got a bit of more we got a
new imagine on deck wow 26 million views
okay this is viral i think putin may
have seen this
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
held in the arms of joyous light
never would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm
so much laughter and joy and nothing
would harm i can't imagine the stain the
soul stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you lived in a
putin's crying right now it just hits it
hits so deep
he's going to step down from power
yeah
and uh go full democracy in in in russia
is this a pre is this an act of war is
this an accident
i think they need to pass this by our
government before putting out statements
like this because this is definitely
this is too far
cruel unjust world
is this why
you now decide no one will get the best
of you
god you are
this is just not okay if only she had
only she had raised him if only putin
had uh been sucking at her mommy milkers
things could be different
by the way you know her kids are messed
up she's like i'm the perfect mother i
would have raised you meanwhile her kids
are like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up because
you're my mom
you keep making these weird tick tocks
instead of playing with me
i'm the perfect mom
i would give world peace to everybody
meanwhile her kids are like
stabbing each other in the corner
oh we got the three million subbies back
oh do we really actually got them like
uh immediately after we made that
announcement so what are you guys doing
not subbed
see that's what i'm telling you listen
you got to just trust me in love on this
kind of stuff
yeah
we have no shame clearly
i feel like i made it this far without
asking for subs
well now you got us
you'll get the subs without having to be
cringe i mean love will do the cringe
by the way i think people are unsubbing
just because of the
the frenemies disappearing
yeah it's a lot of and leading off
probably leading off yes yes and yeah i
mean you've openly uh started to mock a
lot of people that i think at least a
chunk of our fan base is a fan of and
that may have upset some people but like
vladimir
i think the biggest thing really is just
the the the vestiges of the frenemies
subscriber base that that haven't and a
lot of them have hopped over we see
those messages all the time of like i i
was a friend of trish's i started
watching frenemies and now i watch you
guys all the time but you know lots of
them probably aren't interested in this
content and so they're unsubscribing dan
are you aware that you're floating in
the bottom left corner
and me
the bottom left corner has this mini me
and dan
oh he just took it off before i cut
through it
okay you're allowed on this council but
we do not grant you the rank of master
oh
dude don't say that you know what
happened last time they did that
that is true
there you now see i'm back in the corner
dan what the hell is that oh
bring it back now now i want it every
time i cut to it he turns it off so i
can't show the audience who's doing that
i i'm not doing anything
i think it's just when you cut through
it it gets go you have to cut to me
oh it's you're only there when i'm cut
to you okay so i can't show the audience
they're gonna have to take our word for
it
okay whatever
so well okay thanks guys for subbing i
think i guess that's good yeah
we burn a few a lot of people are saying
that we're losing subs because you're
always late
maybe
i'm seeing that a lot in the probably
lost a few that way
you know
certainly is something to think about
well
um anyway back to uh this girl who's
changing the world forever
god she said she'd be such a good mom
dude
fix me mommy
is this why you do not hide nor away shy
from taking back the world it was it
because so early in life all that strife
you didn't have to put you didn't have
to post this
this could have stayed like in the
drafts
you know kurt vonnegut once said one of
the most beautiful things a person can
do for their soul is to write a poem
and then bury it never show it to
another person just do it for yourself
she should have done that yeah
rat to your little body with fear
your little body she just called him a
manlet i was your mother if the world
was cold i'd have died to make you warm
i'd have died to protect you from the
unjust while her kids are in the corner
like the heating's not on they're
freezing their ass off
the violence the terror the uncertainty
i would have died to give you life oh
dear mr president putin
perhaps the torture of unread youth
would not within your heart and view a
scripture to such fealty against that
world that you thought was so how many
times she shoot this
perhaps you would hold dear human life
and on this night instead of
probably like
three or four takes i would guess
maybe more
i don't think she's a one take wonder no
russia you would call me
and i would set your mind quite free
with the love that only a mother can
give
and only a mother can take away oh
when holds she does wait what the [ __ ]
does that mean
she's like i would love you
but also i'd [ __ ] i'd also might
leave you i might abandon you
but not unconditionally
that's a good mother right there wait
let me go back that took me off guard
dude i don't think mothers are supposed
to take away their love that's kind of
the whole point right a love that only a
mother can give
and only a mother can take away
[Music]
chilling actually
i would have left your ass in a dumpster
by kfc you little piece of [ __ ]
that's how he became putin
when holds she doesn't harm at bay and
leaves her boy for the promise of a man
whatever your story mr president putin
i can't imagine how it feels in your
heart but i know if i was your mother
that would be a start
towards the awareness are you trying to
adopt him like what do you want to do
you want to get a time machine i just
she goes if i was your mother that would
be a start like also i'm pretty sure
putin probably i don't know anything but
i know in russia you don't want to make
fun of someone's mom like that's
specifically bad there and she's
basically calling his mom like a
terrible person a terrible mom this is
nuclear this is this could cause a
nuclear war
this is the
the flash point imagine how it feels in
your heart but i know if i was your
mother
that would be a start
towards the awareness of what a powerful
being of light you could be if your mind
was only free from the violence you've
seen when you were just two or three i
cannot believe i was born too late
to [ __ ] your dad
in a different place when i would have
loved you so
watched you play wherever you go
dude you are how long does that go cut
off
dude lady stop it
stop it stop it
i think putin might be getting off to
this yeah you might you might just be
beating i i think he's got like a mom
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
wait what's happening i was replaying
well i think yeah
dear president vladimir putin there
here's a response i'm so sorry that i
was not your mother
you would get so many raspberries after
your bath
real funny ones on your little putin
belly
you laughed so much you'd shake like a
bowl of putin jelly
if i had been your mother i'd let you
stay up late to watch 90 day fiance
you wouldn't understand it but we'd have
fun anyway
if i were your mother
i would rely upon you heavily for likes
on instagram before you were
evil
which would build your self-esteem and
you'd say i like myself the way i am
if i were your mother you wouldn't have
to invade ukraine
instead we'd splash in puddles in the
driveway in the rain
perhaps it's not too late i get it
good stuff though
man
that's tough what is she i wonder if
she's had any follow-up tweets or
anything
from her being lampooned nope nope
let me check she's about to tweet some
replies
nope
she just dropped that bomb and
disappeared not even a like or anything
wow
well
ann lynn
you are definitely the champion
this year
of cringe thank god thank god
she saved the world
um thankfully you know people on tick
tock are also doing their part of course
to stop the war
here for example
hell no god
we need to end tick tock i guess
we need an intervention in china i'm now
pro uh
thermonuclear war with china just for
the sake of ending tick
tock well we can always just launch the
first war the first nuke yeah first
right it's easy it's easy uh
someone said the war just started and
attention seekers are already making
poor content about it yeah pretty
amazing there's been a lot of uh
scamming going on i've been uh seeing
people talk about too what like people
saying they're have doing donations use
this uh yeah this gofundme to support
the ukrainian uh armed forces or
whatever and uh amazing yeah
you think you find phoned one of those
live streams yesterday
oh yeah there's a live stream on tick
tock of someone like breathing heavy and
showing like shaky footage out of the
out of a dark window with air sirens and
it was like definitely looping and
people were donating there was like a
hundred thousand people watching the
live stream and people donating like
crazy yeah yeah wow
quick to capitalize on that one be
careful out there everybody
world war iii sponsored by applebee's
cnn bring in the heat
[Applause]
terrifying
coming up
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's america
that's america
a little bit of chicken fried a little
bit of war in caves
[Laughter]
look at this
oh zach can you play some like air raid
uh air raid sounds i unfortunately do
not have any here let me pull it up on
on youtube yeah libraries at the office
yeah i got you
airaid
siren
here this is what the people of ukraine
are seeing right now it's perfect
here
this this is worth it just give me a sec
gotta
okay
[Music]
[Music]
and a little bit of chicken
oh my god you guys
what a [ __ ]
nightmare we are living in
you always find it funny how like on
youtube people expect so much
from other youtubers like you cannot
monetize any video where you're talking
about anything
a little bit sensitive meanwhile on cnn
they're like just a little bit of
applebee's there's like a live bombing
there's people dying on the floor
just a little bit of applebee's two
entries for five dollars people are like
their head is blown off i always found
that so interesting and some of the
sponsors are the same people that pulled
from youtube in the past but they're
still capitalizing on other tragedies on
traditional media well it's their job
that's what cnn does i mean they're a
news network you know what i mean
but check out our dollar margaritas
margaritas
shout outs
oh so
oh the the caption of this post is the
best by the way it says stop russia stop
this isn't you
this isn't you
this isn't you
if only i was your mom putin's just
having an episode right now
yeah he's just going through something
you know just going through some things
all right well we're above 3 million so
that's exciting okay fresh and fit we
got to talk about fresh no no we got to
talk about the sponsors of this all
right so we'll do our sponsors actually
we have a lot of great stuff fresh and
fit this episode is actually brought to
you by applebee's
just a little bit
try our new
um explosive
jalapeno fritters
explode in your mouth
your tongue is going to be a casualty to
delicious spices
jesus
our jalapeno poppers are going to be
committing chemical warfare on your
mouth
some putin poppers our ranch is
basically white phosphorus stop stop
or try our nuclear wings
the spice is so hot you'll be gasping
for air
check out our new cocktail the ukraine
bombing
try the uh maltel cocktail
special drink
all at applebee's
no no
your mouth is gonna be turning into an
air raid siren when you're just
spitting out heat
yeah by the way uh putin just dropped
this meme on twitter crazy right
like come on dude that's just not
appropriate he hasn't gotten the dub yet
they're holding out well yeah he's
flaunting
he's got the applebee's cowboy involved
i mean that's just poor taste dude come
on
and how dare you include abey's favorite
game
into your
drama
this is this is becoming the crew's
favorite game
involvement playing i think
elder ring bro sorry running around
boomers
yeah people are sick dude
you're going to be wishing you were in
the trenches because this thing
is going to send this thing's going to
send you right to the trenches you're
getting a tomato by the way right it's
funny i agree
it's funny it's funny it's not me it's
applebee's saying that i'm not saying
that what did you guys understand
it's clap it's applebee's that is saying
it you guys
try our uh
try our appetizer plate it's got all of
our appetizers we call it world war
three
because it's got all of them
council approves
all right let's thank our sponsor but we
got so we're in negotiations with the
fresh and fit guys
and they're just such dumb asses bro i
can't so i'm going to show the dms and
talk about what you guys think we should
do because they're making weird demands
i wonder if you guys think it's worth it
we also have to do a wendy williams
memorial for her
dearly departed show
and of course we got to talk about jeff
whittick
he also has demands which i think i'm
going to meet
also [ __ ] louis ck is performing in
russia god there's so much to get to all
right let's think are in ukraine
let's thank our sponsors starting with
hello fresh
man if only we could airdrop abe's
burritos i think we'd all be all right
world would be a better place sure would
oh hello fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
hello fresh cuts back on the time spent
in the kitchen so you can spend it on
other resolutions
with meals ready in just 30 minutes or
less plus quick and easy meals including
20 minute recipes and low prep and easy
clean up options and they provide an
even faster route to putting food on the
table the real interesting thing is
hellofresh is 72 cheaper than a
restaurant meal of the same quality and
you can save on average 65 bucks per
month when you order hellofresh instead
of grocery shopping
the theory on that is because you go to
the grocery store you buy
more groceries than you need
and then you end up there's probably a
lot of waste right
but hello fresh they send you exactly
what you need for each meal
they tell you exactly how to make it
uh they got this cool little card that
tells you how to cook it you can learn a
lot from cooking i know i have and the
food is always delicious
and well balanced for example abe's
burrito
i mean look at that
it's so good it was so good who knows
what's inside of it it could be but
probably some really good healthy
probably some vegetables
probably some meat
probably some cheese
who knows
who knows
do we actually have real food to show
sure yeah
not that it's not real food but
look at that oh my god dude that looks
so good
yo go down what's that one with the
potatoes and meat stop it right now that
looks so good
yeah so this is an example of the kind
of food that they'll be setting you up
with
so easy and so delicious damn duh
those flautas look fire
love it and guess what if you go to
hellofresh.com after dark 16 and use the
code after dark 16
you can get up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts that is hellofresh.com
after dark 16. use the code after dark
16 for up to 16 free meals
hello fresh it's america's number one
meal kit thank you
lego
thank you thank you
hey b
you got thoughts on our next sponsor
masterclass
thank you the master class
with master class you can learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace
did you take a course a b
yeah i'm currently taking the martin
scorsese filmmaking course
i
showed a b's uh burrito by accident
instead of him how is that that sounds
really interesting
it's really good actually um it's very
organized and it covers like all aspects
of
his process you know from his early days
of creating film to production design
costume design it's a really good course
and even in terms of finding an editor
everything you need to know from oh wow
yeah
this website is insane like the actual
people they have delivering classes is
kind of shocking
and they have such high level people on
here
yeah it's really cool to get like these
one-on-one lessons from
legends you know of all aspects you know
from filmmaking to rock and roll
whatever it is
hear that zach
there's a great one with carlos santana
uh amarello which uh really want to
check those out
yeah i mean i'm just a little into
science and tech i was trying to find
the scorsese one i don't know where it
is on this list but neil smoked the
grass chris hadfield that was a guy
who's an astronaut bill nye
not skip bill knight
being good all
who's goodall she was the woman who went
and lived with the uh gorillas and the
gorilla lady yeah
[ __ ] oh
i just realized that way in tarzan the
girl's name is jane
bill clinton's lesson be like
uh don't just you know what
let's move on from that my name's hill
clinton nope
i have to tell you this busy
let's keep moving oh hillary's on there
too let's keep moving
gordon ramsay's on there
uh
yeah there's some really impressive
names on here man
so if you want to learn from the best
uh head on over to master class really
cool
let's see
oh i missed
chad's correcting me they were uh they
were chimps not uh gorillas that she
lived with
my bad
one of them one
idiot one of them apes you know what i
mean well a chimp is a
the orange fella no that's an orangutan
so the chimp is the
like among marvel companies they're the
ones that are most closely related to us
and then so a gorilla i know what a
gorilla is they're apes
and then a chimp
pull up a picture of a chimpanzee if you
would please
like i know what a monkey is and i know
what a gorilla is
you know what i mean and i know what a
orangey tang is
oh so so this is a chimpanzee
so they're kind of like between gorilla
and monkey
you know no no
i mean in appearance it definitely looks
that way to me well i guess yeah
monkeys
they're great apes so they don't have
tails uh monkeys always have tails is
the uh the big difference so like
orangutans uh
gorillas
chimpanzees do you think you could take
an alpha chimpanzee in a one verse one
definitely not they will rip you apart
[ __ ] you
how much do chimpanzees weigh at full
adulthood
because i know a gorilla would like
scare you wrap up the master class i
know a gorilla would tear you limb to
limb yeah the chimpanzees will too
what's the weight tell me with the
weight of a chimpanzee real fast and
then i'll move only less than a human
but they're you they just have raw power
eh yeah they're strong
a dull 88 to 130 limbs oh bro come on
yeah that's nothing i'll tell you what
the chimpanzee does after the ad after
the ad will yes i was going to say after
the ad i could fill you in on some
stories
i mean i heard one word okay let me
finish guys i highly recommend you check
it out get unlimited access to every
master class
and as a listener of our show you get 15
off an annual membership fun
go to masterclass.com
slash after dark now that's
masterclass.com
slash after dark for 15 off masterclass
so go ahead and
get learning y'all
thank you knowledge
knowledge
where's tai lopez on this site
yeah weird
today i'm going to teach you how to not
read a book
i read 50 books a day i spend 10 seconds
on each book
i skim remember when we had that
revelation
tai lopez says he reads 100 books a day
and then he revealed that he's just
skims them
like you're not reading it you idiot
yeah so you want to tell me about why
chimpanzees are so dangerous
they're those you know that this is
we're stepping on joe rogan's toes here
this i'm i'm intentionally doing that
okay the whole fight ones we want is a
got it is
there's just horror stories they've done
something i've heard she like took one
tore a lady's face off yes
but that could just be
that could just be that he had he just
got lucky with any you know what i mean
it's happened to multiple people they're
just proficient at tearing faces off
they like to
destroy anything that is
not stuck to your body or like fingers
and toes and she's like ears
so what would you rather fight a
chimpanzee or a gorilla
a chimpanzee yeah easily probably a
gorilla no stop it at least it'll
[ __ ] break your neck or something
probably yeah yeah it's true kill you
fast yeah
you have a chance against an 80 pound
chimney though they're like crazy strong
though it's like
ants they can lift like 100 pounds over
their body if they lock onto your face
i choke that monkey out okay
i'd go right for his kidney
all right whatever you guys say do we
have can you pull up a video of a human
fighting a chimp
please no no we don't have that yet
well there's only one way i'm sure there
are videos but that you want to catch a
guy
no i don't but you actually think
there's a video of people fighting
chimps there is yeah there's like 9-1-1
calls and they're like horrific they're
like [ __ ] horrific
and they're not fights well yeah you
have a while you're not trying to fight
it if there's a crazy chip in your eyes
i'm talking one-on-one man-to-man combat
fight to the death
like the chimp might take you by
surprise if he's like a pet in your
house and he tears your face off then
you're already at a disadvantage
would you would you fight the ch yeah
i'd take i'd easily take out a chimp i
grabbed his little hands
yeah this fact says chimps are about 1.5
times stronger than humans relative to
their body mass good thing i weigh 300
pounds
makes me stronger still
wow
chimps are impressive
all right so let's talk let's talk we
got so much to get to all right so
fishing fishing for fish and fry
fresh and fit we had discussed last week
about inviting them on the show you guys
overwhelmingly supported having them on
to debate me and hassan
uh 70
so we reached out to them and you guys
tell me uh what you think so we said hey
come on the show
first we said
here i have the whole conversation here
first we said
uh let's just do a zoom call because
they're like in florida and i it's just
it's just a stupid little it's just to
have a conversation it can easily be a
zoom call it's just not that serious i
just want to talk to the goons
and they then they go here let me pull
it up this conversation is unbelievable
this has been
booked over and censored right
this has been censored is there any
there's not any personal identification
i'm hearing a lot of silence from the uh
from the council
shaking his head no
no
there shouldn't have been this yeah
okay just making sure
so this is the whole conversation here
so it said would it be with ethan or is
he going to bring someone else uh it
would be ethan with hassan he says why
not do it in the studio i'm like
okay i mean
dude it's not that serious but if you
want to fly out here
and if you're vaccinated then sure we
can do it in the studio so we said guy
are you located in miami right we
figured it'd be a lot easier just to do
it over zoom
would that work for you he said yes
miami i understand you guys film in l.a
or we have business to attend to there
anyway so we can do the debate while
we're in town i said okay are you
vaccinated
he says we have documentation
that was the first red flag
[Music]
i said documentation what do you got i'm
just it's just yes or no bro
picking coconuts from barbados yeah what
do you
the [ __ ] you mean documentation
i said can you go ahead and send proof
of vaccine vaccination to our producer
at dan
or dan's email which you all have by now
and so
by the way everybody shares proof of
vaccine here all of our employees have
to submit their proof of vaccination
very normal
i don't think it's that
that invasive to to ask for and by the
way he literally said i have
documentation so i said okay send it
seems reasonable he says but we can but
our personal identifying information's
on the document can we take a covet test
prior to entering the facility
i said just block out the information
well this is ian talking to them and
we're having like a chat in our group
chat about it can you just block out the
information
so it's private and just show the proof
of vaccination
he says okay we can do it virtually
which to me
and i'm making an assumption here about
you guys tell me what you think
he says we're vaccinated
it says okay well
show me your documentation
whatever that means
and then he's like okay never mind
the dude was gonna come i don't think
they're vaccinated
that's
who knows there's an assumption i'm
making i don't think they're back i
think it's a fairly safe bet because
like let me pull up my vaccination card
it's on my phone let's see how much
personal information is on this thing
and the point of course it has personal
identifying information that's literally
the point to prove that this person is
vaccinated what are you afraid i'm gonna
but like it has your name okay so right
here it
has
it just has my name and the data
vaccination
and and a registry number
that can be looked up in a database to
make sure it's authentic which i think
is the real reason that they didn't want
to send whatever they want
or whatever they wasn't even going to
[ __ ] scan it or whatever i just
wanted to see you're tripping
so they were going to come here unvast
you know the tests are not super
reliable guys it's like 30 reliable at
this point
the quit the rapid tests
i mean it's better than nothing but also
it's not good enough also
yeah i mean just send your [ __ ] proof
of vaccination it's not a big deal
but i guess it is i guess it is if
you're on facts so or if you have a fake
one i'm not saying they do
right i
i don't know that at all but i certainly
want to wouldn't want to send a fake one
yeah go ahead a b i've seen people
discuss it on reddit
two months ago and they're saying that
they're not faxed um they were asked in
a live stream and supposedly they said
they are anti-vex yeah of course they're
alphas
alpha males alphas that they
lie about being vexed instead of just
well they're so alpha they go yo we need
to do it in the studio i says okay fine
dude and then they're like i was like
are you vaccinated they're like yeah i
was like okay just show me your
vaccination you can come okay let's do
it over skype then never mind
you beta beta behavior dude
okay
and then it they continue
we said when okay okay let's do it
virtually like i said in the beginning
what would work best for you guys we can
do next week but we want to have rollo
[ __ ] tony this guy they said we need
to have rolo tomasion i call him rolo
tony browntown
because of that tim and eric song
she said it will just be predominantly
myron is that the the main guy which
one's myron which one's myron i just
know him as fresh and fit yeah
myron i believe yeah he's the he's the
main guy
he's not coconuts in barbados
he's not no he's uh no he's the other
guy myron gaines
it will be predominantly uh myron and
rolo
doing the talking
we think it will make for a good
discussion between ethan and his son so
he's he's once again icing out his
dumbass partner who i keep being like
why is this guy even hosting a show his
brain barely operates dude's talking
about coconuts and barbados and now when
it comes to debating us two on two our
show the leftovers first third show
fresh and fit he's icing out his homie
again in favor of this guy rolo tony who
we did some ops on apparently he's like
the quote father of red pill
the problem is i don't know anything
about rollo tony and i just don't care
about him nobody cares nobody wants to
talk to rolotown i won't talk to fresh
and fit they're they're the guys
that's just so absurd rollo tony
browntown
you know you got to give me some more
i don't know why i always loved that
song
great tim and eric made a a pitch to
rolos as a bit
[Music]
rollo tony brown town
give me some more of those rolos
uh i passed this along to eat wait so i
just i told ian to tell him if you don't
want to debate just say so
because it's like how many conditions
just call into the [ __ ] show i think
he would prefer to have a discussion
with just youtube since that was the
clip that you two started yeah two verse
two
we are happy to debate by the way and
this is the guy who just last week was
like stop ducking me bro have us on the
beach stop ducking me
come on call i'm not asking any
conditions you and your boy
you and coconuts call in and we'll talk
if ethan is bringing hassan we
respectfully request to bring someone as
well you you're there's two of you and
there's two of us and hassan is a
co-host of a show yes on this channel
maybe they don't know that
i'll tell you the benefit of the doubt
maybe i don't realize that hassan is a
co-host here i can do it by myself if it
makes them more comfortable it's just
there's two of them i don't it just
seems silly for two people to be
debating one person
yeah
i mean
the other guy he doesn't really count as
a person it's like one it's debating
like one and a half people
but according to them he's a real person
i mean he's half of the show i just
trying to prove a point like i was like
i am specifically going to try to have a
conversation with coconuts and barbados
and see how that goes and they're like
nope he's out
they know better he's on the bench we're
bringing rolo tony
he said how do you know you won't bring
someone like crowder i'm like
like you did with crowder i'm like first
of all nobody cares about you guys this
is just a stupid gag
sam cedar and crowder had this like
crazy uh
beef going for years where crowder was
dodging sam cedar there's no lore where
bringing someone on is interesting or
funny okay dude you said stop ducking
and now you're being such a beta like
who cares even if i do bring someone i
thought you [ __ ] could support your
can you support your well it's just like
crowder it's like
sam being there shouldn't have been a
reason for him to immediately just
completely crumble can you support your
your your stances or not what does it
matter yeah anyway i'm not bringing on
anyone because nobody cares about you
guys you don't have like an arch nemesis
that will [ __ ] be like oh i've been
avoiding you for 10 years it's just not
interesting dude
people saying abba and preach that
actually would have been oh
right they did have oh that's what
they're afraid of that might be i was
wondering what they would were afraid of
yeah that would be it's funny that chet
is saying that because that's the joke i
made when we first
i was wondering i was wondering if it
was that one girl that demolished them
but i was like i don't see why that
would be a big deal it's definitely abba
and preach
because they had that whole ongoing
copyright yeah they instructed their
channel they basically destroyed them
and their responsibilities
well
i don't even follow them you can look on
twitter i don't even know i've never
spoken to those guys i prom i've nev by
the way i never promised crowder
anything that's the thing i never said
or did anything i'm telling you now on
camera i'm not bringing ava and preacher
anyone else it's just me and hassan
i'll even do it by myself i prefer to
have hassan though so it's a two-on-two
conversation
yeah and i know hasan was excited too
because he's familiar with these guys
yeah he's talked about him a lot on his
channel so
also if i'm not mistaken i ever went on
their podcast and confronted them like
face to face
oh so there you go it's not like
uncharted water yeah so they're not even
like ducking him
yeah i don't know
people are people are spamming coconuts
in the chat
just bro you said stop ducking me you
stop ducking me
stop being a baby dude i thought you
were the alpha and i'm the beta right
i'm the fat beta so stop being a [ __ ]
baby and just come on and talk to me
about your dumb ideas you idiot loser
well
listen probably not gonna encourage them
to well then don't come on but don't
don't tell me that i'm ducking i'm not
ducking [ __ ] i'm right here call the
[ __ ] in any time
i'm not ducking you're ducking
in fact i'm gonna start calling you
[ __ ] daffy the duck
damn because all you do is duck roasted
let's start calling you uh
roasted ela just uh
oh eli just donated she called him stale
and unfit
[Music]
let's go ewa ela kleiner
[Applause]
oh you hear that stalin unfit just call
into the show
by the i'll say in his um defense he was
very polite in the dms which i
appreciate
yeah
it was a fairly professional
conversation except for the part where
they seemingly lied about being
vaccinated right that's not that that's
not professional he did it in a polite
way i suppose
yeah just stop dude if you want to say
i'm ducking you're daffy [ __ ]
i'll start calling you daffy
because all you do is duck
so i said let me think about it but what
do you guys think should i have rolo
should i let them bring rolo tony
browntown
or just
be like dude it's duvers do this is what
it is who the [ __ ] is rolo brown you
said that he's the the father of the red
pill wait didn't we have some content
about him i wanted to talk about rolo
tony yeah i i'm not caught up on here so
let me give you a little bit of of info
about rollo tony brown town so here's a
clip of him
the rational male okay so okay cool oh
this is a short okay so
let's see what role you've got to have
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and this and
if you don't have it you're not the
perfect guy in fact there's a poster so
is that rollo tony browntown
who put this
that's rolo tony okay
who are you love about to act up
hey i have no clue who i am but it's
it's an actor who i don't know the name
of
girl what's up what you doing
you want to get some popeyes later or
what you like spicy
i'll pay for you girl
[ __ ] i'll teach you some crust uh chris
cut fries
you can hook me up with that uh spiced
chicken no pickles
whatever you want girl [ __ ] take it on
the side i'll take those pickles
anywhere
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
come on now
[ __ ] dog trick and donkey
all right let's watch rollo tony
the perfect man and of course it's this
guy with his shirt off he's got you know
let me go back you gotta have this and
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and if you
don't have it you're not the perfect guy
in fact there's a poster of the the
perfect man and of course it's this guy
with his shirt off he's got you know
ripped abs and everything he says the
perfect man is that and it's all this
list of crazy and brings me ice cream in
bed at the bottom of the
thing right and it's this
is he getting all pissed off by like a
boom like a zoomer [ __ ] like stump
[ __ ] post about the perfect man
this is why i hate all women i saw a
meme on instagram once with 10 likes
and i decided to kill all women on earth
and only have sex with dudes it's like
there's such a a a laundry list of
qualifications that the guy has to have
woman
hot available yeah that's it those are
the two things and you know what you
can't even understand that you can and
you still with all of this bullet point
checklist you still
don't want to give that up you spill
because think about this all of those
all those qualities what women are
effectively saying is
my [ __ ] and my body and my sexuality
and my agency is worth all of these 436
bullet point checklists that's an even
balance yeah that's how magical my [ __ ]
is i literally don't know what you're
even talking about dude but it's kind of
incredible how like just a bunch of butt
hurt dudes who can't get a girl because
they're such like toxic freaks just get
around and make theories about like all
women based on their limited experience
it's incredible
wow
okay so that's a little taste of rollo
not that bad pretty standard red pill
stuff here he's showing off his chart of
development of women over time
he has charts yeah he's got charts oh
fascinating
why they even want this guy on like he's
not even he's not like a big deal or
anything why are you bringing a roller
coaster
mentor or something
um this year this guy taught me how to
hate women properly bro he's a genius
he's got graphs
my uh timeline okay that is so low res
yeah let me turn that up and also the
volume's a little high if you could help
me out with that i got you
of uh what you can expect from women at
various stages of their maturity stop
what is that
second part is the rational male
preventive medicine
and in that book
so this guy's basically a scientist i
understand
i totally understand why
a lion's share of that book let's just
say is uh dedicated to helping men
understand what they can expect
generally generally
understand
what women's imperatives what their
priorities are going to be
i don't need to listen to talk
hear their teens
super insightful bro he goes 15
to 16
teen
sick
okay
break party years the party goes from 20
to 27 then they have an epiphany
competition anxiety
security anxiety from 30 to 35
development this is [ __ ] unhinged
redevelopment reinsurance security from
age 50.
we need security now just so chaotic
there's so many labels and overlapping
lines and it's just like so this is the
alpha short-term alpha re-interest
bro i'm sorry dude but i'm just saying
it i can't what i can't debate a guy who
brings out a graph like this you're like
this is so stupid
what point in the graph do you pee in
the basement right that's somewhere in
uh the security anxiety portion
but like he's a small he's way smaller
than they are red pill lions this is his
channel sick let's go to most popular
let's see
oh [ __ ] the red pill lessons of will
smith
women can have anyone they want here
let's watch this a lot of guys
particularly the black pill community or
the mgtil community oh no not blackpill
and mgtows this is the worst or whatever
want to say well women like a woman like
hershey can just spread her legs and she
can have any girl any guy she wants yeah
that is true but here we have an example
of a woman who
by by their by that definition could
certainly do that but she's not she's
venting her frustration on tick tock on
a one minute video
because those guys she doesn't want
those guys she doesn't want that
attention she doesn't want those
particularly she can have anybody but
she doesn't want just anybody because
women's mating strategies and women's
sexual imperatives and their mating
imperatives are different than men's
so when you think like that you're
thinking like a guy and you're
projecting that that ideal onto women
why the [ __ ] did anyone watch this dumb
like this is so dumb this guy's actually
as dumb as they are
so
i'm sure it would be interesting with
rolo tony but
i'll tell you what's going to happen
it's just going to be we're going to end
up debating rollo tony because the other
guys are not secure in their opinions
and then it's going to be ethan versus
rolo tony and fresh and fit are not even
going to be involved i don't care about
[ __ ] rolo tony i want to talk to
fresh and fit so you guys vote i'm i'm
leaning after watching this he's not
even interesting he's going to take over
the whole conversation i'm leaning no
rolo tony on this one
sorry tony
you're still paul
i mean we do we even need to nobody
wants to hear about this guy
let's do a poll just so we can be like
yo listen bro the people don't want
roller tony
people want the two hoes versus two
hosts
bro coconut barbados sits on your show
every time you do a show why shouldn't
he represent the show
i mean if you think he's dumb just
remove him from the show and get and
then have rollo tony co-host
you know what i mean
i'm not some barbados
yeah that's a no for me dog that's like
the most overwhelming it's the most
overwhelming vote we've ever had yeah it
could be like it was hitler a bad dude
it would have less
polarization
coconuts and barbados
picking coconuts in barbados
he seems like a nice guy the coconuts
and barbados
i think he just got wrapped up in some
weird [ __ ] you know
i feel like coconuts and barbados could
be happy doing anything in life
he just wants friends you know what i
mean like he doesn't care about red bull
[ __ ]
i wish he found a better hobby
i think you're right
he could be playing bocce ball or
something you know
be just as happy
you know i mean he could have any hobby
in the world
i'm meant for it
man this bio that uh
cam just sent
here guys
rolo ton here's a bio about rolo tony
browntown that he totally didn't write
by the way
sometimes called the godfather of the
red pill rollo tony has been a permanent
fixture in the mannose sphere
don't say that word
the atmosphere don't use that word for
20 years it's time to get out of the
manosphere bro
we're on to the metaverse now yeah i
think the man's fear is done this guy's
going to die talking about
bread pill he's going to be set like i
don't know he looks old this guy is
going to be on like dying alone without
a family talking about red pill [ __ ] i
mean what a sad way to live your life
well the focus on evolutionary
psychology yeah i've seen what i seen
that graph i see where this is going
an objectivism oh rollo brings a
pregnancy what a surprise he's a
libertarian
i can't believe it i'm in total shock
right now rolo brings a pragmatic nuts
and bolts
approach to intersexual dynamics
men and women's innate natures
and their effects on today's society
cool
yeah i'm not interested dude
that's a that's a hard pass on rolo tony
in fact you can write him ian and just
say that's a hard pass on rollo bro
sorry
you two are welcome to call into the
show anytime and i'm giving my scouts
honor my pledge
right now on camera i will not
bring anyone else on in fact i'll do it
by myself if you feel more comfortable
because i know coconuts and barbados
doesn't count as a full person
you might even be a negative person
because you got to deal with whatever
dumb [ __ ] he says and clean it up
he might be half a person
so you tell him ian that
two on two
one on two
but i want coconuts there because i want
to talk to him
as well as you know i want to get to
know him a little bit
you said he seems like a nice guy
coconuts yeah
don't you think so no
it's misunderstood yeah i think he's a
sweet guy he just fell into a bad crowd
do you think he's like doesn't even
understand what the other guy is no he
doesn't care about red pill he just
wants to belong to something
that's what i'm saying he could [ __ ]
pick up any hobby in the world he
doesn't even know they're streaming
every week people are demanding hassan
by the way so i want hassan too but like
okay so then it just it needs to be me
and hassan versus coconuts and uh
barbados oh i love that tank
yeah we need hassan i agree
just a quick update jstation changed his
instagram profile picture to uh putin
what a legend bro guys
let me check you guys
putin's invading you crying at 3am
dude what is wrong with you you're such
a [ __ ] weirdo dude
ugh
you are so strange followed by
starkiller
been watching his actually stabbed keep
that i've been watching him for years
he might block you man why does amy
follow him someone said okay
he will he'll never he'll never
vlog well maybe he will now but whenever
me and him had a back and forth i told
him go ahead block me like you do
everyone else and i was like i know
you're going to do that he's like no i'm
not going to [ __ ] block you so he's
making a point about not blocking i got
ahead of that yeah years ago so i'm good
do you like his post like it's a little
intimidation factor no no i want him to
forget that i follow him but oh so
you're stealthy okay
stealthing
stealthy we don't talk about stealth
thing
love it you're terrifying looking man
that didn't didn't mean frightening me
confused i'm sorry it was a deep cut
reference
deck is inaccessible best forgotten i
meant like quiet that's what i meant
yeah
i won't stealth jstation i got you yeah
you need consent to remove the
the johnny
sure
what's next so there you go so no co no
rolo tony sorry
up next
man this is sad news sad sad news guys
wendy williams is retiring
this really hits hard because
she's provided so much to us
yeah and she's asked for so little in
return yeah
after 13 seasons the wendy williams show
is officially coming to an end
a spokesperson for wendy's i made
wendy's
made the following statement it's been a
challenging time for wendy as she deals
with her health issues
she's incredibly grateful to deb mar
mercury
to sherry and everyone else who has
supported the show i don't care about
this pr [ __ ]
dude this is
that's very disrespectful i'll play some
sad music or something
there you go
she more than anyone
understands the reality of syndicated
television
oh
you just can't go to the marketplace are
you guys okay
oh no you guys are so yeah no i get it
you can't go to the marketplace and sell
a show that's maybe the windy show
she understands why this decision was
made from a business point of view and
she has been reassured
by devmar mercury
that should her health get to the point
where she can host again
and if she wants to host again
she'll be back on television
[Music]
if her bowels are uh strong enough to
hold through a show
we'll have her back on yeah or not
let's be honest her on-air farts have
been the most viral moments of the year
so
let's keep that up eh
[Laughter]
yeah i have to remind you guys that's
actually a real sound bite of her
farting that's not edited
[Music]
play that again zach gonna miss those
wait that's gotta be edited why is it so
long you're always
you're always doubting it and we've done
we've done an in-depth analysis on this
one wait hold on please get played again
[Music]
you just played it
what happened
how could it be so long have you ever
ripped the ass like that long
it's like a whole
narrative
it's not like a beginning a middle and a
whole arc yeah
she she has uh ibs or something right
like she's she's she's tooting all the
time
tootin putin tune putin [ __ ] the only
thing that's added to it is gain
turn it up right
wendy has been absent
since october
uh health concerns
she did faint on television in 2017.
yeah love just demonstrated that um uh
here it is
halloween
costume contest we do it every year so
it was a lot of fun let's get started
our first caress
man that's such a crazy moment actually
weird [ __ ] slip and then she comes
right back on that's that's look at her
hey guys it was not a stunt i'm
overheated in my costume and i did pass
out but you know what i'm a champ and
i'm back
dude how do you come back from that's a
true entertainer right there how the
[ __ ] was she not rushed
probably should have been
yeah that looked like a stroke the show
must go on that wasn't no that wasn't no
he overheating in your costume
looks like he's seen god man
wow like a movie yeah so that was what
happened but we want to go over some of
our best windy moments um i think it's
important to
to pay uh homage to her
what is this hibby
oh no
promoting ibs awareness month april is
ibs awareness month do you know
about aerial bow syndrome with
constipation
oh this is sponsored
she was paid to post this [ __ ] bro
she's the official spokesperson of ibs
well
yeah i'll be the expo i'll be the
official spokesperson too if they pay me
okay do you have ibs i will if they pay
me you have gerd is there a gerd
organization out there
wait who's paying her for this who are
the ibs awareness people
the dru some drug company
yeah ibsc
what the [ __ ]
can you imagine the uh the board
meetings there
everyone's ripping out ripping ass back
and forth
yo how much do you think she got paid
for these 30 like posts i mean this is
just such a weird post like nobody's
going to engage with this
who are we retweeting a a chart about
ibs well somebody might just be browsing
the ibs awareness month hashtag and come
across it
you gotta
you gotta get out there true
all right so let's go over our favorite
windy moments and ethan educate yourself
says the chat
yeah you're right
sorry guys
very serious this is a very serious uh
conversation we're having here about
farting i didn't think ibs was even that
serious he just means like you're you're
kind of well it can be serious i guess
sir but
it just means you like are a little
poopy
sometimes you [ __ ] yourself sometimes
you fart it happens
isn't that everybody though
like i said every fart on her show was
an ad
every every fart was sponsored
this fart was brought to you by
pepto-bismol
that's pretty good
all right here is the infamous fart and
moop sound
you're lucky you oh wait was that was
that the real sound okay no sound no
sound effect zack no that that was from
the video i wasn't playing anything what
the hell i still can't believe what i'm
hearing and the way she's leaning over
too
you're lucky
dude what the hell
that's going to be one of the best tv
moments
of all time
just a matter of time she's not lonely
i apologize i apologize
[Laughter]
that's what she said and you know what i
what was that
she's so awesome
wendy shooting uh shouting out kim
cantel after her brother was found dead
um
this was where she said i have more she
was complaining about his tick tock
having
or something let's watch there's been so
many yeah i don't watch lifetime all
weekend i didn't get caught up in any
many movies
and i didn't see any sex in the city
by the way a shout out to kim cattrell
her brother was missing and i saw on the
news feed this morning that he was found
dead
yeah right
this one before the classiest transition
of all time
samantha or samantha from sex in the
city so but i didn't see did did anybody
watch sex in the city over the weekend
a [ __ ] you kind of just killed the vibe
a little bit
many movies
and i didn't see any sex in the city
by the way a shout out to kim cattrell
is it normal to shout out people for
their child
dying shout out
shout out to the island i just love the
pause between found and dead she's like
excited to talk about it
oh by the way
her brother was missing and i saw on the
news feed this morning that he was found
dead
yeah samantha
from sex in the city so but i didn't see
did did anybody oh and by the way shout
out to my good friend uh eric his family
perished in a his whole family perished
in a
plane crash but anyway
shout out to the ivan well actually
uh
shout out to the family
i guess dead people do get shout outs
shout outs
uh here she is screaming die die die
about um
the conservatorship
i would let them both drown too jen i'm
going to tell you why
and i mean it uh first of all ben
affleck gave me a five million dollar
pink ring
we bought a beautiful gone with the
winston one in georgia
i put you in the bentley and we did the
video together we paraded on the red
carpet and you break off the engagement
and embarrass me
die mean and to twist the knife even
further in the ben affleck jennifer
lopez thing is that it's not even like
he's not the marion kind he went off and
married the other jennifer and they've
got kids
died
[Applause]
you had me speeding through numerous
traffic lights doing gun play in a
nightclub
you remember
you had me do the purp walk and spend a
few hours in jail
die
and they've got kids
yeah she's fantasizing about
killing
um
what's her name's uh
boyfriends
what's her name jennifer lopez yeah
um here this this is a good one
this happened very recently and it kind
of took us all by surprise
even her audience was like wow wendy
what the hell was that
fantastic stuff here watch this i have
no idea who this is neither does norman
neither does one person in this building
maybe sus does uh do you know who swavey
is
clap
clap if you know who swaggy is
okay
sauce nah
it's not my
it's not my cup of tea
that i got going on right now well he's
a tick tock star he's got more followers
than me
2.5 million
no no
we don't like that on tick tock but on
instagram you have more followers
hell yeah
man [ __ ] this guy who does he think he
is having more followers in her own tick
tock anyway
what about him
well as my son kevin would say no one
uses instagram anymore
what and
as far as tick tock i don't use that
at all
i don't know what that is i don't want
to be involved
so here he is
he's 19
and he was murdered
monday morning
[Laughter]
what a memorial she really knows how to
uh
send someone on a phone for a while
dude that is just
why wasn't she at the funeral to deliver
a beautiful eulogy like that
how dare he have more tick-tock
followers than her
anyway he's [ __ ] dead that's how she
does it
she's like anyway i'm glad he's dead
he had more followers than me
she's crazy man no one can replace wendy
no one
no one
yeah
clap if you think she should suffer
talking about harvey weinstein's wife
harvey weinstein's wife by the way
remains such an enigma to me she's like
this beautiful supermodel
they were married for a while
there ain't no way she didn't know
what's up but that's a different
conversation
should she suffer
all right clap if you think she should
suffer
yeah i'm curious what she had in my what
she has in mind tell us more wendy
yeah some things we don't clap we don't
you know i guess we take a poll should
she suffer should we take a pull
see what our audience thinks yeah should
she suffer should wendy should should
harvey's wife suffer
i don't think we should right okay just
because yeah
uh wendy
announcing trey flap emojis in the chat
yeah i mean listen
how could she not know but i don't know
what she means suffer like i really want
to know what she has in mind
like iron maiden
[ __ ]
drawn quarter torture
yeah
wendy william announces trey songz
allegedly beat his girlfriend
sorry but i know this can be bad before
complimenting his body holy [ __ ] she is
just one of a kind man
so trey songz was arrested yesterday she
got that zebra fit bro
for allegedly beating up a woman
that he was dating they were at a party
there were a lot of people around who
witnessed this according to the woman
he was charged with felony domestic
assault
isn't he just so dreamy
i mean [ __ ] way
no way
holy [ __ ]
i don't want to believe it but you could
you know these days you just don't know
what to believe but he's got the dreamy
stare and
he's nice and tall
he's yeah yeah
he he's built like a swimmer like he's
got a swimmer's body like not too
muscular just you know
yes
he allegedly punched her repeatedly
talking about how strong he is right and
then goes into how he punched her
this is how chris brown gets away with
it by the way oh my god he is so strong
he's so perfect body i love him anyway
he allegedly punched her in the face
with those perfect muscles
people at this party
so great
we love her don't we folks how much of
the audience agreed too did you hear
that they were immediately like [ __ ]
yeah he's hot
holy [ __ ] perfect body
to punch me with
[Laughter]
classy group but ladies god damn i'm
telling you no one can replace wendy
never they'll never be a replacement for
her
wendy discusses the murder of drew
carey's ex-wife oh boy
we gotta get her just doing the nightly
news the more she talks about murder
and horrible crimes the bet the more
good content we have
oh lord
drew carey's ex-fiance was tragically
murdered over the weekend
which um was pushed off of a third floor
balcony
i'll give you a little backstory
so she was killed not by drew
but by by the ex come on down
oh god
oh lord lord lord oh my god so bad
you know it's bad when the audience
doesn't even laugh oh go ahead
i've seen that one prior i think this is
the first time i saw it it's amazing i'm
just confused by that
i think that was in the intro of his
show wasn't it
yeah
the person
and she was like come on down the price
is right
she saw the third window yeah so drew
carey pushed her and said come on down
that's what uh wendy actually says to
her
farts and poop when she poops herself
she goes come on down the turret is
right
you guys see why i don't
i was about to say we very much should
have watched all of these before making
fun of her farting i was just gonna say
you guys see why we're comfortable
making fun of her she is
as entertaining as and beloved as she is
she's kind of a terrible person a little
bit or at least just insensitive to the
point of like cruel
so we're just we're just uh returning
the energy yeah
golly
making weird noises after spilling
coffee this this is a classic you know
this is one for the history books here
it's okay it's okay it's okay yeah
exactly you know i'm alive right
thank you wow this guy knows that uh
crisis was nearly the show almost ended
right there
what are these noises guys it sounds
like a cat dying i've heard cats die in
israel there's lots of strange cats
there well you know what it sounds like
i'll tell you exactly what it sounds
like give me one second
she sounds like a cat dying i remember
once i'm very s it's very sad but
there's a lot of straight cats in israel
and uh one of them was just dying
outside my window for like a day
it sounded just like that
then
okay
sorry dan's going for something
and vocal cords with a 3d so they
they uh
scanned a mummy with an mri machine
and recreated the vocal cords and were
able to reproduce the sound of what they
think that the mummy sounds like nessie
a moon's voice by recreating his mouth
and vocal cords with a 3d printer it
allowed them to produce a single sound
what's my god it's like
it's totally [ __ ] windy
it allowed them to produce a single
sound
play the windy one yeah it's okay it's
okay
wait why did they do that though that
seems like the dumbest use of time
i've ever tried it's a human being why
would they sound different than us
that's a great point they're literally
the same animal that we are
same exact species that we are
what are they saying if the mummy were
to be reanimated and talk
that's what it would sound like are they
saying that's how people sounded back
then which again same exact species
very weird cbs morning what the [ __ ]
dude
and
yo we have this ground breaking sound
we spent millions of dollars researching
this and rebuilding the vocal cords of
this mummy
listen
[Laughter]
making fun of joaquin phoenix's cleft
lip yeah that that one was just so
unnecessary you know
i didn't really get this one and
when he shaves off his mustache he's got
a hair line fracture he's got one of
those um what do you call the cleft lip
yeah flat palate
he's got this yeah he's got this no i
find it to be i find it to be very
attractive
she's coming from my boy man
right oh he's a joker he's one of the
jokers that's actually zach's sa patriot
patron saint coming from a boy man
that's so [ __ ] up dude i mean it's one
in 1 000 babies that suffer from that
and not every family could afford to
deal with that it's
such a [ __ ] thing to say yeah it's
pretty sad when you can't get it fixed
but i just it's like she's 12. it's like
what are you doing why are you doing
that motion
weirdo
oh wendy had of course she's to prove
how educated she is
by the way she's suffering of covid
right now
which i laugh about because of this clip
you'll understand
are you planning on getting your vaccine
no
no
no
i don't trust it
wendy williams dies at age 54 of kelvin
let's not make that joke when that
could happen in the next level she's not
vaccinated
am i supposed to feel bad
she'd probably be fine if she got
vaccinated
am i supposed to feel bad
she's got like a bunch of other things
going on like i can't even
i can't keep up with all the uh
cause i'm gonna do a win if she dies
she has graves disease
graves disease she has ibs and and she
has like early onset dementia i think
that was not confirmed that was just
something that was floating in there but
it seems like it really
right
if she dies at covet i'm gonna do a
wendy williams-esque
send-off
like anyway i'll be like yo eldon rings
is crazy like i'm on this boat oh anyway
did you guys hear that wendy williams uh
passed away
but uh anyway eleven rings is so [ __ ]
fun right now i don't know that's not
even good enough
flu shot either though and you and i
have talked about that and several of
the doctors on my team talked to me
about wendy we'll get the flu shot
i've never had the flu i'm not getting a
flu shot i very we never had the flu
she's never had the flu
by the way she's not exactly a picture
of health either and she's a little bit
old so i like how she's like no
i'm not getting that i get a cold i
never have headaches
i don't take an aspirin because you
never get sick you just fainted on stage
like
what are you on about i feel my heart
murmur or something like that i'm not
getting no i don't trust it there i said
it
i don't trust it
well i gotta say i i disagree i think
the vaccine is sick i gotta say uh
speechless you're a [ __ ] idiot
she's also said she's never farted on
her show before too yeah well that that
was a delay
right
zach has she farted on the show
nope sounds like it jerry confirms
wendy
or the fart
the fart of the century yeah exactly
wendy williams and with another classic
line
this one's about
a brittany's uh conservatorship are you
mr spears you had me fooled
and you too mrs spears death to all of
the audience seemed them think wendy
would
she scared herself
and the audience as well like we get it
we all don't like you know jamie
we don't like jamie spears but like damn
girl you got to chill a little bit
look at her
and you too mrs spears death to all of
them
even the audience seemed to think wendy
williams went too far
she shocked herself it's like she has
like intrusive thoughts
oh my god
yeah that's that's one of my favorite
sound bites to all of them
and you too mrs spears death to all of
them
even the audience seemed to think wendy
williams went too far that commentary is
fantastic too i love the jesus on there
jesus
death to all of them
and finally guys wendy williams is
shaming jennifer lawrence after nudes
leak oh man
oh this is the same [ __ ] episode she
fainted on
so she came back just to uh
shame jennifer for someone stealing her
nudes
i think it's the wrong place
oh this is her faint thing yeah
okay
stand by stan bye
uh there's one above that you missed
clap if you ever wanted to kill somebody
she got so many death related ones that
really makes me wonder
so
clap if you've ever wanted to kill
somebody
okay lots of clapping
and she's like well i have don't look in
this location
[Applause]
clap if you've ever wanted to uh
brutally
disembowel someone and eat their organs
so is this a missing clip ian
yeah i'm not sure where when i'm trying
to find it
wendy williams is shaming
well
here let's just look at the row two we
made a memorial
to send her on a boneva
bon voy voyage
and uh well i hope you guys all enjoy
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know what's going on i don't
know you're gonna oh you're gonna
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] was that imdb rating it
was the rating for a show
holy [ __ ] that's bad
3.3
did she get brigaded or something well i
think a lot of people
hate her because of all these horrible
things she says all the time but
obviously a lot of people love her so
as much they hate her
i have the momentum i don't know
all right
excuse me
it's a matter of time she's not lonely
i mean
you're lucky you only got better i have
never farted once on this show as a
matter of fact
i barely fart i farted i would have
definitely been left because farts are
always funny
oh excuse me
what was that by the way a shout out to
kim catrell her brother was missing and
i saw on the news feed this morning that
he was found
dead but i didn't see did anybody watch
sex in the city over the weekend died
i have no idea who this is neither does
norman well he's a tick tock star he's
got more followers than me on tick tock
but on instagram you have more followers
so here he is
he's 19. and he was murdered
monday morning
clap if you know who swaggy is
okay pop if you've ever wanted to kill
somebody
all right clap if you think she should
suffer
death to all of them
songs was arrested yesterday for
allegedly beating up a woman there were
a lot of people around who witnessed
this he was charged with felony domestic
assault
isn't he just so dreamy
i mean
[Applause]
i don't want to believe it but you know
these days you just don't know what to
believe but he's got the dreamy stare
and
up next trey songz and i have a big
surprise for everyone in the audience he
allegedly punched her repeatedly in
front of people at this party drew
carey's ex-fiance was tragically
murdered over the weekend
not by drew come on down
are you planning on getting your
backseat no
no
no
i don't trust it
[Music]
wow
tragic thank you wendy
the sound bites will be missed
so true
man it seems like every month we were
getting new
fantastic content from earth yeah that's
a shame
so guys uh
wish her well and i hope she comes back
i really do
really do
uh what do we got we got uh jeff okay
let's talk about jeff
also known as jets apparently according
to my typos
yeah so jeff put out a a pretty gnarly
video oh you got something oh the the
one i missed of wendy
i'm yeah it's pretty good i feel like
one more wendy clip that we missed she
deserves it she's breaking her silence
about the nude hacking scandal i'll read
what she says and then we can talk okay
just because i'm a public figure doesn't
mean i ask for this it does not mean
that it comes with the territory it's my
body it should be my choice and the fact
that it's not my choice is absolutely
disgusting
it's not don't you disagree with that
wendy
don't you dare disagree with that take
your choice it's in the cloud and i've
looked several times
so i guess i'm disgusting for looking
clap if you looked at jennifer
lawrence's hacking pictures
clap if you're lying because you really
did look
there's always one in the crowd
besides jen you don't look bad under
your clothes
and this i think the heck elation has
actually made your career even hotter
because she was red-hot before but now
it's like
heat-seeking missile hot jennifer
lawrence you want to know what
don't sweat this young lady i mean
you're the one who took the picture
addicted to based on your nasal passages
and all these days
i think there was more but cheap but
like yeah i mean
someone stole her private photos that's
not that's not part of the gig dude yeah
anyway
the judge mathis saga was really good
too
oh god i can't even get into that that
one was so so crazy
all right let's move on to jeff so jeff
uh put out a podcast
uh yesterday night or this early this
morning really early some stuff called
dear david and where he
puts out some really interesting uh
information eh
so
let's watch from here came out on a
patreon live stream it was supposed to
be more private to just 100 people but
you know things got leaked out and now
it's world news you know we're going to
war with russia we're going it's world
war iii
and a breaking news is that i unfollowed
david dobrik on instagram
i love that because there's
this conflict in ukraine nobody's
allowed to talk about anything else like
i saw lana rhodes be like uh
why is everyone talking about my crypto
scam when there's a war in ukraine
it's like well
i can't i'm capable of caring about two
things at once believe it or not
he is a slimy [ __ ] you know [ __ ] he
can't even get a job because of you
wait who's he talking about me
no he's talking about david okay wait
let me go back a breaking news is that i
unfollowed david dobrik on instagram he
is a slimy [ __ ] you know [ __ ] he can't
even get a job because of you
[ __ ] expose my life to 20 million
people who needs to put in a job
application anymore i did that
at all fairness i i did make a video and
you get out of prison too yeah so
we one time we were at air one and uh
it's a very uh high end you want me to
watch all this maybe
i mean it's it's all about david i mean
he's talking about how because david
given this character of a criminal like
can't go anywhere because
they associate him with being a criminal
because he was a criminal on the vlog
okay i'm gonna oh i'll watch i'll watch
it grocery store it's like a fancy vines
over i mean he does keep threatening to
like kill me
so he's not i mean
he's playing up to the role he's
thinking about
uh jeff's friend i'm saying jeff plays
up the criminal thing the schtick right
he doesn't want to be associated he
should drop the stick
price
they recognize cody from the
david vlog where they picked him up from
prison and cody you know this is just
like a staten island thing where you
you'll like grab like a cookie in the
circle you start eating this supermarket
and then you keep the wrapper you pay
for it on the way out but they came over
and tried to lock cody up because of his
reputation that was given to him by dd
for a seven [ __ ] dollar cookie they
profiled you yeah but we're back and i
want to just talk about some
i know it's not what we're talking about
well what the [ __ ] was that story he
stole a seven dollar cookie and got
arrested what what what what's the
context here
why is that david's fault
he's saying that because in the vlog
david painted him as a criminal his
friend is a criminal that usually where
they're from you could eat something in
the store pay for it on the way okay
yeah but because they recognize him for
the vlog they thought he was stealing a
seven dollar cookie and seven dollar
cookie
what cookie cost seven
dollars
i don't know the golden one a [ __ ]
how big was that new york baby oh my god
you know
seven dollar cookie
inflation is crazy right now dude
i don't care [ __ ] where you're shopping
man ain't no seven dollar cookie
anywhere the place is insanely expensive
like insane it's a seven dollar cookie
look like
we can get you a seven dollar cookie
show me a seven dollar cookie i'm sure
somebody
council
i implore you points because i i've been
protecting this guy for so long and
there's so much more to the story than
just him not texting me for a week after
i had such a drastic surgery where i
could have been blind but i just didn't
plan on that getting ripped because on
patreon we have that that audience of
maybe 100 people in a live stream where
i feel like i could just talk more
freely it felt really good to get that
off my chest it felt good to get that
out there
it felt good to hit that unfollow button
you know i woke up from surgery
and a day goes by no text from him
another day goes by no text i look at
his instagram yo what though his homie
just start [ __ ] pumping iron
during the show
what's he doing
because he's the first one to always
[ __ ] you don't necessarily being
criminals oh go ahead bro i'm gonna pump
iron while you tell your story
no we're not criminals yo i'm gonna do
some push-ups here where you tell your
story all right
what the [ __ ] is this
i'm trying my best not to like
i'm trying guys [ __ ] pops up because
algorithm or whatever i'm gonna do some
curl ups while you tell your story all
right
tim like oh i'm so happy with my life
right now my vlogs and everything
uh just promoting his vlog and
i was just like you got time to do this
but you can't text me and be like hey
did you go blind or not from my actions
i just want to [ __ ] tell the truth
finally yes
yes jeff we want the truth that's all i
want i love
i love it tell it i want jeff to sue him
he really should he really [ __ ] his
life up i really think jeff needs to sue
him
i gave this [ __ ] so many chances
even now a week later i still haven't
heard a peep i've been posting [ __ ] on
instagram because it feels good because
you [ __ ] me so bad mentally and
physically yeah that yeah this is how i
cope now you're not holding back no more
no i'm not holding back anymore um i
kind of pissed off that you know even in
the documentary we made
we sugarcoated it there was so much more
that i could have said but i tried to
protect this guy for so long it takes
time to
see people's true colors even me and
this guy right here we've had horrible
fights we fist fought each other we grew
up together
we've had moments where we didn't speak
for years
but we always seem to find each other
and come back and meet at a moral ground
we can talk things out and communicate
but at this point i've just completely
given up and it feels good you know i
think that you're just more like going
through a lot of emotions because at
some point you did click out with these
kids
and um even like not to sound emotional
anything because the best thing that you
ever did for me was the distance
yourself from me because then i was able
to find myself and find my path but i
think like it hurts you more than most
because well you were on a lot of drugs
you're robbing me
it's a bit of an aside
but um
dude
jeff i feel like he's just trying to
justify
he has to justify it so much because he
doesn't want to be the rat
david ruined your life bro he doesn't
well i don't want to say ruined your
life because you it's not like you don't
have anything to live for you have
plenty to live for you know
uh but
he he mess he he he
he did you wrong man that's why that's
why lawsuits are there
i'm glad you're speaking your mind
is there somewhere else i should skip to
uh maybe
jeff here
is there if you want to go to around
1912
should i watch more of this or what are
you just going to talk about i mean it's
depending how it's just going to how it
made them feel to see you know the vlog
squad uh i do want to hear it but
there's just a lot of asides and stuff
here that's kind of tough it always it
goes right back to jeff his friend
interrupts here and there then kind of
people you were doing all the time
when i got out of prison oh yeah then
you're that was a different stop
associating me with criminals anyway i
just got out of prison
and i stole a seven dollar cookie
he didn't steal it he was gonna pay for
it more hurt because you are a good guy
and you are a sincere friend but that's
the thing i do see the best in people
and i do it's funny that you're here
today because you know hey ethan i see
the best you know i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you when i see you
you could go to 19 minutes i think
maybe he's like please get away from
this plan this i was just going you did
this baby that's on instagram he warned
you like yo this shit's funny that
you're [ __ ] going
oh [ __ ] i love this [ __ ] well that might
close your ears i love this [ __ ] it's a
funny coincidence that you are here on
the show today because we've been
through so much and you are terrible
okay you know what let's just do one of
these i'm imprisoned at empathy in them
they are too narcissistic to he was a
friend and i thought that he had i
thought he had good in him this
hollywood should smoky mirrors there's
more to why i'm pissed off and why i'm
lashing out and why i'm finally speaking
up
then just him not texting me i could get
over that i realized over the past few
months and years of him not giving a
[ __ ]
that that would probably happen i'm not
surprised and i'll be dealing with the
[ __ ] for life so you know i don't expect
him to text me every year i could be
eight years old and go through another
eye surgery and have him [ __ ] text me
yeah i i get that the real reason i was
mad it's gonna come out publicly in a
month anyway but david filmed the
documentary and the producer of the
documentary creator of the documentary
director whatever you want to call it he
called me facetimed me to show me the
clip of the interview when david
addressed the situation with the crane
and he said that it was my fault david
blamed me for the the great he
insinuated that i was crazy i always
want to push it
and
i'm the reason
that this happened that's crazy
that is a revelation
that's that's that's crazy
um
jeff's the one controlling the current
or
david is the one controlling the crane
with one hand and another hand on a
camera
right
well that's funny because he also and
it's his it's his content ultimately
yeah it's his responsibility no matter
what well man i really do feel bad for
jeff he's so and he's so angry and he
should be
what a piece of [ __ ] david is such a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
when that's complete [ __ ] there's 20
people on the beach that are witnesses i
have [ __ ] six terabytes of footage of
you asking me begging me to go out there
and do the thing again and that you
would spin it slow you just want to take
me out there because it's more scenic
see that i would like to see he says he
has footage of david begging him to let
him take him out
that sounds like good
courtroom evidence jeff
you know what i mean
and it looks better on camera it's more
cinematic and just to hear him
sit there and say that i was like in
shock at first because i'm looking at it
over facetime and i just couldn't
believe that he would say that not only
does he not really give a [ __ ] but
imagine you smash somebody's skull in
they take it on the chin they don't sue
you they don't [ __ ] press charges i i
mean anything we could have i would
nearly die they came an inch from death
and yeah from going blind i'll have the
one thing about the mafia is you gotta
take care of those that do the time you
know what i'm saying
if you ain't gonna snitch you gotta take
care of him he's serving time he's doing
the best thing he can do for the family
you're right david that's the he missed
the number one rule you gotta take care
of they take it if they do on time you
got to take care of them you know
because
he's got a lot of reasons to go against
the family
he's breaking the number one rule
lifelong brain injuries and save them
from [ __ ] everything you would have
got deported what's this homie doing now
he's tying his shoes
are you listening
you got it
you gotta this is jeff's best friend if
you want jeff to come on the show do not
make fun of him he's not even paying
attention he's tying his shoes he's
lifting weights you would have gotten
out in jail for manslaughter you could
have got sued he's like what'd you say
can you can you say that again for me
maybe it's just hard for him to hear
this about one of his close friends
sorry i wasn't listening fidgeting he's
fidgeting yeah hey hey jeff i wasn't
listening can you say that again
for everything i took it on the chin and
then to see this and that just made me
completely
lose all respect for this guy and lose
all hope that he could ever turn around
and become a better person you know i
know he does a lot on video he gives
away cars and [ __ ] like that but you
know doing stuff on video and doing
things and well he's paid to do that
jeff just to be
the sponsors par
pay the cars and pay david to do it i
think that was his point well he says he
does good things but it's like not on
video i mean yeah i mean the sponsors
pay for all that [ __ ] real life are two
completely different things yeah you
know what i mean this fake [ __ ] i know
exactly what you mean that's why i stay
away from it yeah i don't condone that
[ __ ] honestly i don't even know how much
we can get into yet i will we'll see how
things play out all right let me go to
19 minutes but that's real interesting
yeah i can imagine how bad that would
that would feel to see david be like it
was his fault i mean what the hell bro
you can't really say that
right after the accident
we all stayed in the airbnb together you
know i uh my jaw had a bunch of plates
in it i couldn't chew i had to live up
in shores for the month and
did you hear that dave abby said it's
this is too far
yeah i clicked your no you clicked your
go to 19 minutes 19 first and then you
go to this okay
19 minutes
career over your friendship well there
was no friend of course friends wouldn't
do this you know friends there's not a
day that goes by that i don't think
about
why he took me out there and spun that
so fast because we never agreed that we
were supposed to go that fast
this is where everything went wrong
i don't know the relationship i doubt
it's animosity i think david just thinks
of he doesn't think of him as a human
being he doesn't think he thinks of him
as a
someone that
to do make content for and meet puppet
yeah he's just he's not a human being
there's no consequences all that matters
is making the best video he's literally
a meat puppet he's like a marionette
hanging from that yeah exactly that
[ __ ] excavator
so i i mean i don't know the
relationship maybe maybe he does
and this is the one [ __ ] up thing
where i
kind of see the line of an accident
and intentional [ __ ] i mean i mean
it's negligence it's it's straight-up
negligence if he killed you it'd be
manslaughter it was just
you got to sue him jeff i think he needs
the closure he can't let it go and how
could he he's so resentful and he got so
messed up he just he really really
really needs to just sue him bro trust
me man you're
done not even for the money just for the
closure
it's blurred but he asked me to come out
there three four five six times asked me
to go out there one more time just
because it was more scenic and we were
supposed to go slow
the water was one foot deep
if i would have flown off that thing
it's a lose-lose i die that way because
i'm going 60 miles per hour i would have
flown [ __ ] 100 yards and died in the
one foot water that way or i braced for
impact and just pray i had no choice
once i started swinging i kind of think
it was intentional because so these
thoughts crossed my mind but if if he's
i don't know yeah it was intentional i
don't think he was trying to hurt i
don't know what do i know but that's
david he's a sociopath he doesn't think
about the human consequence
but that's crazy man that's that's so
messed up he goes yo i'll be i'll be
slow i promise
and he he yanked him so fast on that
thing
around i don't talk about it all day
every day but if he's just around and
tries to be a good friend then i can get
past that but everybody still says to
this day you made a decision to get on
that rope which i understand i did i did
make a decision and i'll have to live
with that but you did it trusting that
he wasn't going to slam you
right and to the side of it and i mean
it goes without saying but this whole
notion that david was trying to say that
jeff was trying to push it again it
doesn't matter like when it's your
content when it's your
you're the producer you're the owner of
what's happening if somebody is pushing
to do something dangerous it's on you to
say no not to and if you go along with
it it's your fault yes it's his
responsibility 100 even if and i don't
believe that that's what happened i
don't either but even in that
circumstance that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
like it's still david's fault but i
don't think so either i think if you see
the
because corinna went first and everyone
got freaked out because it was super
scary and then they're like okay jeff
hugo i don't think it was like a go push
it harder david like no way he did that
it was a stupid one i was never the one
to [ __ ] do the stupid stunts
but in this situation
i was on a high from skydiving he got me
at that moment an accident did happen
and that's fine because accidents do
happen in life
we both [ __ ] up hey is this some lint
on this couch
you can't roast people for having a
short attention span
i sit here for three hours every day
that's epic dude
wait hold on just let me just say
accident did happen and that's fine
because accidents do happen in life hey
where'd you get this couch i'm going to
live many times
we've both done terrible
yo you got something on your couch what
do you say you say something
hey wait did you say something he's a
huge influence or a huge star
[ __ ] what the hell is this photo
can someone explain what i'm looking at
he's he's he's comparing the situation
to logan paul and the forest
but he's he's messing around and used
these images like logan did something
controversial and he acts like it's
beating up his friend but now he's
accepted now he's a good guy i literally
don't understand anything you just said
took a long time off
i mean i think it's your fault i'm just
going to learn from his mistakes
a respectable guy
yeah i mean well
that's
that's the biggest
no hate to jail but logan is not a good
guy he literally did like two massive
crypto scams just last year
like three months ago
i mean there was dink doink and then
there was even another one yeah
he's he he is not a good guy
i mean
okay ethan yeah okay we can get into it
later you know he's come a long way
david
nearly killed me
came back to poston immediately
while i had my face smashed in lost all
my jobs couldn't work for a year yeah
and posted like nothing never happened
doing tick tocks i mean that's exactly
why you suit you lost work
you lost the potential to work
you're physically injured so there's
actual costs
it's got to happen doing house tours and
comes right back like this is everybody
else is crazy on the internet i'm not
i'm i'm the i'm the sane one why is
everybody mad at me for i don't know i
think anybody would like swinging
somebody from a crane would have been a
little bit more delicate with an actual
human the that machine is heavy
equipment like destiny his friend makes
a good point
you'd have to be psychotic that to be
that careless with a human on the end of
a crane
you know
yeah he'd use it for demolition it's
just insane we even got into it
afterwards because you told me i was an
idiot for getting on it yeah i was kind
of upset
i should never said that but i was just
more like no no it's cool i was more
like hurt like damn why the [ __ ] would
you do that but it was like
i get it like you know it was just [ __ ]
being done heated at the moment like you
know peer pressure content and it's just
like
[ __ ] was just happening so is there
something oh he talks about me or [ __ ]
is there more jeff talks about not being
able to eat after that accident david
making pancakes in front of him let's go
i love that
much because right after the accident we
all stayed in the airbnb together you
know i i my jaw had a bunch of plates in
it i couldn't chew i had to live off in
shores for the month and
that's gnarly david made pancakes and
bacon and i had i hadn't eaten in four
days and i'm just like
[ __ ] is that his sound or yours
that that's his song he did that sound
yeah i guess he's got a song
yeah he uses the same david's left that
we use like demonic life
that's throwing me off i couldn't chew i
had to live off and she hey i got a text
hold on hold on to that story jeff i got
a text
what'd you say i live off in shores for
the month and
david made pancakes and bacon and i had
i hadn't eaten in four days and i'm just
like
why the [ __ ] they play laughing sound
bite that's not that's a poor party time
zombie
i'm trying to get into the story but
[ __ ] this is this is
so relatable but also so long too
yeah
so there's relating it to a
lyric from a kanye song whenever kanye
got hurt in his accident and he had a
line about how he couldn't eat he had a
drinking shirt and he's like well and i
couldn't eat basically david was cooking
in front of me not caring
can you play laughter sound bite zach i
got it
wait did you think i was trying to be
funny no no no no
i was just trying to hit the vibe
he was also playing like cha-ching
sounds and then whatever you said there
were like david laughter
coconuts and barbados
you can't be playing cha-ching sounds
that's that's not it
we've we've ascended cha-ching right
zach i mean every occasionally i'll i'll
play that but it kind of transitioned to
like a mario type sound
pissed off at your friend from it
um
but yeah
kanye docks great it's incredible to see
him meet forever
okay
jeff talks about coming on our show he
sent me his demands by the way i'll tell
you guys it's pretty good i'm able to
meet it his demand outro you got any
more anybody else you want to call out
over here
h3
h3
i'm supposed to go on your show i'm
thinking about it
i got a few lists of requests
that i need approved and i i need to get
some things done before i agree to walk
in on that show
don't worry about sending over the
address already got it
is that a joke like
that's what i'm saying he goes i'm not a
criminal i just know where you live
i don't get that joke he does that too
where he's like i'm gonna do something
about it if you don't cuvees
i'm gonna do it for you
that i need approved and i i need to get
some things done before i agree to walk
in on that show hang on there i got a
text
hold that thought there jeff
hang on i'm on twitter
hang on there's something happening on
twitter hang on
yo
check this tweet out
she got big knockers
yo check this chick out you got big
knockers on twitter hold that thought
don't worry about sending over the
address already got it you know the game
what's he doing with that is he joking
because it's not clear to me if he's
joking or not
i mean i don't think he has the address
so maybe he's just doing like a wise guy
joke
and you'll find out after the episode
i'll maybe i'll just not give him the
address and see
if he asks for it or not
[Music]
it seemed like he was saying it in a
joking one it was a joke
god it had a jokey vibe it did
well he was like i got a series of
requests yeah he's like he's doing a
little stick there he's doing stick okay
when abc's told me that he said that
because in the past he has threatened
you in dms as we've talked about on the
show i was like seriously like this
guy's still doing this but watching that
clip i'm like ah
he's joking can i give some advice to
his to his editor or switcher or
whatever
if one of the if the guy's on his phone
not paying attention
don't don't show him for like an
extended period of time all about making
peace baby
i don't want to
like that shot
probably better not to show him just
idly on his phone joe
don't worry about sending over the
address already got it you know the game
this is like a shot where they uh
the the sound goes quiet and you hear
his inner thoughts
man i'm gonna have meatloaf tonight for
dinner
i might drink some beers and watch espn
is this show still happening
about making peace baby
what a shot why cut to this
they may have needed to maybe uh they
were
a cut yeah because this is an edited
podcast right they don't do it live so
they just needed to cut away maybe it
was edited yeah okay it's a cut they're
masking but they could have used a shot
of him listening they didn't have to use
the shirt maybe they were you know yeah
it
it's not it's not just an it's not the
best yes it's true it's true
i don't want to have enemies out there
but there's some bad people in this
world not me i hope that deserve it
so hopefully
this is it
is that them that's good that's a good
soundbite never ends
leave a comment down below if you think
i should sue david yes
leave a comment down below if you're uh
100 hey are we done with this yet i got
[ __ ] to do
dozen likes us who did an attorney and
satchel he's he's he's he's actively
texting limitations is up or if you know
anything about that stuff
it's my fault honestly it's my fault
you're 100 million 100
well
abe said don't make fun of his friend
let's be respectful i probably wouldn't
even have noticed if you didn't say that
i sure i was watching it back with lena
this morning and i was telling her i i
asked ethan not to comment on this and
she's like there's no way he's going to
resist
i'm like no no i'm sure it's only if
only you knew me as good as she does
comment down below
leave a comment down below if you're uh
yeah yeah the show's almost over i'm
just waiting for him to wrap it up he
keeps crying about this and that to be
fair
to be fair to him he probably didn't
think they would cut away to him like he
doesn't know yeah exactly right jeff's
over there talking he assumes the camera
isn't just like focused on him that's
true yeah i do that sometimes i'll check
my phone you know yeah
so that's that's a good point
get an attorney and
stature limitations is up or if you know
anything about that stuff
i don't think there's yeah i actually do
talk to me jeff i i have really good
attorneys one
and also i don't think there's a statute
of limitation on civil crimes and also
it just happened yeah it was like a year
ago you're good now you're good a little
over here and actually the fact that he
paid for your legal fees is probably
even good because it shows him
uh the mission of guilt right exactly
taking responsibility for it so it's
kind of even can is a good thing
probably
cody you read a lot about law in
yeah listen i wasn't listening
full suits is there a statue of
limitation i think like seven years or
something then you it's five years for a
crime
my cousin vinnie
your honor i wasn't listening
can you say that again
sorry i they see
okay whatever
yeah jeff suem i can if you actually
have legal questions i can help you with
all that stuff i'm pretty good with all
that stuff and i'll put you in the right
direction with with uh lawyers i have
really good
connection with lawyers
oh he also tells me to stop printing his
patron
uh let's pull this up
that's funny
and stop ripping our patreon live
streams and making them public they're
supposed to be private well stop putting
good gossip in there and i'll stop
showing it also we talked about me in it
like come on now
for the people
there's a rat in the patreon we gotta
find
that stuff's supposed to be personal
that's funny
all right that is funny okay
listen
am i being too hard on them i'm just
joking around i'm sorry
am i being too hard on them
maybe
it's funny i mean you're offering to
help the guy with legal
i know but i just i don't want to be
such a dick people want to associate
with me but i'm sorry i'm just trying to
be funny
and i'm sure there are people that
probably don't even want you to do that
so
you know
but oh yeah his his terms this was funny
you guys will like this
he hit me with those terms he said
i need uh
three ice cold lacroix if it's room
temperature i'm walking out of there
verbatim that's what he said
i said you got it buddy
i asked what flavor
what flavor let me see if you responded
what flavor lacroix you want see he
didn't respond
i guess we got to get them all
yeah i'll uh
i just wanna have a test i'm gonna
invest in lacroix i said well let's get
like a white a white wine tray you know
with the ice in it
put them on the ice
there you go huh
david broke the cardinal rule somebody
put all sirens and said you missed the
part where david didn't he says that
david didn't pay for his medical bills
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa where's that
evie is that in here
well you wanted to give him a joy but
yeah
well we'll time stamp the part that's
relevant not the part where his friends
are scrolling aimlessly on his phone
you know
thinking about meatballs i mean it was
probably in one of those sections that
we paused and moved on from basically
what he said if you want me to just say
time stamp
we have the source in front of us
all right
thank you
in the meantime
that that can't be he didn't pay for his
medical bills didn't they say that in
the documentary he made is that was that
was that not the case or maybe he didn't
pay for all of it well he said that he
was going to i guess it might be a
matter of well that's a lawsuit you
gotta at least pay for the guys medical
bills he's living in a 10 million dollar
house if he's got to sell his house to
give him money he should
you know
he was paying but they overlapped um
and it was like a ding on his computer
he said he missed payment yeah he missed
payment
left him with broken credit and he can't
buy a house because of it holy this is
all coming from the chat so
wait so david missed a payment
that's what it sounds like or maybe jeff
missed the payment because
because david hadn't wired him the money
for it or something that would that i
guess that would make sense for why his
credit would get affected
i see
that's that's dirty man that is dirty
dirty
you got you got a million and one
reasons to sue him and they're all legit
my friend
well while we look for that there is
good news actually coming out of russia
louis c.k is performing in the capital
of ukraine
uh kiev
what
you didn't hear the update about this
what that it's not happening yeah don't
ruin the joke i know i saw the update
thank you dan who cares if it's not
happening
despite ongoing uh russian aggression in
ukraine louis ck is performing
at the national palace of arts in kiev
this weekend wow that's crazy this
information is according to a fan who
retweeted a message
dear attendees louis ck performance will
still take place as planned
the tickets for the show remain valid
and new dates
do not require an exchange this is
exciting so
um louis ck down bad
it's hard when you're cancelled man you
got to go to war-torn
countries to sell tickets
wait this guy says it has not been
canceled
that's from three days ago
i mean it's funny who cares if he's done
i thought it was very funny when i found
out about it and then it was a lot less
funny when i found out that he never
went well in truth uh i guess he was
planned but then he canceled yeah i mean
it was a show yeah apparently it was
only 11 bucks to see him perform
i set the time stamp
thank you bud
no problem
but i mean listen
the show must go on
he could probably show his dick there
and at that price they might not care
if he pulls his dick out
you know
a little bonus for louie
jeff's idea he's crazy complete [ __ ]
that's number two number three they were
supposed to cover the hospital bills
they slacked because whatever the [ __ ]
they're doing making stupid vlogs they
didn't pay attention to something that's
i would think it's pretty important here
because the the bills go to my name and
our agreement was just cover the
hospital bills i don't care about
anything else i don't i'm not coming
after him from money i lost from not
being able to work or anything like that
but i got
a bill that wasn't paid that i didn't
know about because i'm not dealing with
it i have i've been my
assistant deal with it and he goes with
david's team and they didn't pay a
[ __ ] bill i got an infraction on my
credit now i go to get a house and i
can't get a loan because now i have
another so just like things are piling
up over and over again and just try a
little bit for those who think i'm
trolling or i'm [ __ ] crazy on
instagram so it sounds like he is paying
them he just was late or something
yeah he was negligent yeah again he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] right
it's in his name right he needs to get
the treatment he's like i can wait
there was another sound bite in there
too
it was david saying i missed the mark
without one oh they just did
yeah i won't go that far i think that's
the least yeah those those are the
obvious ones to take
yeah i mean i agree
jeff uh it seems like he was really
i mean you can tell he's that kind of
guy it's like his his buddies is he's
like loyal to a fault too and um and
that has
led him very astray at times with the
other whole situation that he got in
trouble for yeah and then with this yeah
i mean he justifiably should have been
completely [ __ ] furious with this guy
and was letting him off
pretty much as easy as he possibly could
just like just help me pay for my
medical bills i'm not even going to talk
[ __ ] i'm not going to blame you
i'll publicly work with you still
it'll be fine and david still [ __ ]
kicked dirt in his eyes yep like crazy
well he elaborated he should sue the
[ __ ] out of him he really should i
totally agree yeah
go ahead he was saying how he went
through a breakup uh prior to getting
close with this group and like he was at
a really low point in his life and even
you know to this day like he feels so
bad because he's close with so many
other members of the vlog squad so
yeah it's a shitty situation yeah
well they shouldn't they shouldn't hold
it against him i mean otherwise it's a
cult if they can't understand why he
needs to sue david
then they're in a cult man i don't know
what to say it's like sick
like don't they care about what happened
to you i mean
you know
well anyway that's that um
so hopefully jeff still wants to come on
even though i've been kind of a dick
but i actually do genuinely like and
feel bad for him he's your best friend
he said
he's my best friend
there's so much more to talk about but
we feel that we've been going for a
while eh uh yeah we're at uh
2 40.
keemstar stuff
nah
not today we spent a whole [ __ ]
episode two days ago on him [ __ ] him
yeah uh what oh this is who's the debra
yoha she's the oh the girl who eats the
gnarly [ __ ] oh giant hot dog dipped in
mail
love it i'm gonna look away for this one
let's save that that [ __ ] tick tock
that uh was it zach who found that yeah
yeah i straight up gagged like i i let's
just watch
this
so first of all where do you get
something like that like i think it's
just a roll of meat right like you could
get at the grocery store like it hasn't
been cut yet
right
so you oh you you you hit these up in
sweden
yeah it's called follicore
and what is it tastes like it's just a
hot dog it's just a big fat hot dog
baloney
it says i i tried to translate it it
says lightly smoked balloon
okay it's baloney yeah
yeah
so do you condone what you do were you
even gonna tell by heinz that size damn
girl what the hell
this is so yeah just feast your eyes
guys uh i need to know need to know
god lee dude
even the sound is horrible it's just
there's this just ain't right
what you're doing is not right
avery asked if this was terms of service
this is tos violation
i mean
it looks like it is but i don't think so
when i first saw that thing i thought it
was tos
i have my eyes on the chat right now i'm
not looking at the video well it has 2.8
million likes so clearly someone likes
this thing
i'm curious olivia's take on this
because she said she does like the
chewing
and stuff like that yeah the chewing
doesn't bother me it's the giant
pink tube of goo dipped in a bucket of
mayonnaise this is my new favorite tick
talker
i'm infatuated debra
wow she gets a lot of views here this
one has this one has six million views
eh
oh my god
chill damn
yo you gotta chill on that the chat is
going ballistic they're telling me to
shut it down i can't i i am not i'm not
uh at the authorization level too
you guys hate it so much then why does
it have so many views
oh no this one has 12 million it looks
like 12 million views it looks like
chicken feet
girl stop it
no no no no no no stop
stop stop dude i love that [ __ ]
stop it
i don't like that one this one has 55
million views i mean she is a superstar
you guys
just a fish straight up
what there's bones in it and stuff
so gnarly
oh
she is a carnivore man she is she really
is savage
and i mean that in the full form of the
word
okay this one has 51 million views so
oh jesus
nope
no no no no no no no no no
what was it wait apparently she doesn't
need it based on the comments you don't
see it it's a it's a plate full of
maggots i
was not joking about not looking at the
screen right now
it's a plate full of maggots i'm just
switching by feel
i'm just trusting that it's on the right
thing i can't do that
51 million views dan don't be a baby
i don't i have a mask on i don't want to
[ __ ] puke into a mask that's strapped
to my face
here this one has 42 million views
[Music]
bread and
honey
doesn't seem crazy
bread and honey
she's just dunking big-ass little dried
breads and honey
that's why i'm fine it's just not that
bad
people saying is they are meal worms not
maggots
okay forgive me yeah i mean
to all the biologists in the chat uh
i don't want to eat either either a meal
or not
oh she's just eating a bottle of fanta
you should look at this one dan
she's just eating a bottle of fanta is
she gonna eat the wrapper
let's see if she eats the wrapper this
is fake
yeah yeah it's just like a gummy bottle
that was like a trend on tick though
right
okay if you're so impressive i want to
see you eat some tampons like shoe nice
oh true let's see mukbang some tampons
like the goat yeah he is the goat
incoming 20 emails from shoe nice now
that i've mentioned it's been a minute i
wouldn't mind an email i hope he's all
right
he's been on the reddit yeah
for real all the time
all the time he pops up on my for you
page
is he a hit on tick tock yeah he's
pretty popular
yeah i could see that wait what does he
talk about on the subreddit
he just posts his videos what's his
videos yeah oh it's just software very
toxic community apparently i saw last
time our community is very toxic
according to shoe nice i don't want to
even mention it
well why are you just self-promoting in
our in our subreddit just if you want to
add to the convo
you can't just
he posts and then he deletes his own
posts pretty often too
he does that he does that on youtube
he's the king of that really
here is an avocado is she gonna eat the
peel or something avocado dipped in
honey
there's nothing in her mouth what is she
chewing she's already chewing and
nothing she didn't even eat anything
look at this
look okay nothing in her mouth
oh yeah she's going to eat the peel
oh wait did you take off the peel or she
eating it
it's peeled yeah it's peeled i mean that
one that's a clean peel that's a big ass
avocado man yeah
this one don't bother you
i mean it's just avocado with honey i
mean it's she's eating it kind of gross
but
i kind of feel like not like maggots or
like
pink baloney dipped in mayonnaise
you save me i feel like this is your
personal revenge against the chat for
commenting on your chewing
how can how can 50 million people be
wrong
because 15 million people are like look
at it they're sending it like can you
yeah sending it to us okay well that's
the top comment is some
some is really wrong with you you know
i just saw hold on i just saw a chat
comment that's interesting because
on that last one
why is using the same audio every time
it did it looked like it looked out of
sync to me
when did that avocado video well hold on
we can chewing sound started before she
even put it in her mouth if i click it
we can see no it shows the original as
this
one but why is there already chewing i
mean there's still ways
there's still ways to run if she edits
out
why would she she doesn't need to reuse
the sound look it's the same one just
just go back to that avocado one you'll
see what i'm talking about
she's chilling
oh yeah she's slapping her lips yeah i
would i was saying how why she chewing
before
nah that's real but she has no need to
fake that it's the real deal
all right
do you need more evidence no i believe
you you're right
let's skip forward it's just weird
we may have found someone who loves
eating as much as me
new frenemies maybe more than me in fact
what is this thing
oh it's just fried chicken
and mayonnaise
oh
gnarly dude
no way
that's a lot
that's a lot to deal with at one time
i need to process what i just saw
i love that [ __ ]
we're about to go go down below three
million
oh no
no we're not cuz i'm gonna plug it again
at the end wait how many subbies did we
get
what are we at
we gained a few or what
or was it just like a little i think he
was just kidding because of the chewing
no i know but how many subs do we gain
i'm gonna shake back then yeah
how'd we do
how we do
drumroll
we were at
12.999
oh it says 3 million thirty six
thousand
three million thirty six
thirty six thousand yeah
no no thirty six
wait we have three we only gained thirty
six subs
are you [ __ ] serious
wait what how do we know where we're at
before and doesn't it take
no it takes time
hold on i'm logged in i'm logged in i'll
okay
i see the exact number no you're right
and it went down now it's at 3 million
15.
because we're saying that there's only
39 they're gonna they're gonna
unsubscribe to get us below three
million now because we said there's only
three but that means your your guys's
master plan is not working
yeah we were ten thousand below we were
ten thousand we got ten thousand what no
we weren't
there we were like maybe two hundred
below it was like just below three dude
we got we oh my god now we're back below
3 million
oh my god you guys it doesn't work
there's nobody nobody wants to subscribe
now we're back now we're now we're way
below 3 million so good job guys
okay well we're not we're gonna do
something if we hit three moves we're
not coming back until we're over three
million
yeah
yeah
we made that call
[Laughter]
i will eat one of those baloneys dipped
in um
nobody wants that we just lost more subs
yeah
oh that's true yo you got i thought i
was like 36 000. that's great now we're
down
this is not good
we're self-serving let's just stop
talking numbers stop talking about it
stop talking numbers you were the guys i
mean you guys you're the ones that
brought it up you said listen to me in
love we know what we're talking about
and a winner do you know what we're
talking about i'm surprised you didn't
know better not to mention that there
was 3 million and 36 subs
45 000 it was less it was like five it
was like
it's like nothing over it 14 pages
lisa lundy donated two dollars and says
i have been subbed since day one lisa
wow
wow
see that's all we need we only need the
leases of the world the leases
we don't need the fair weather
subscribers that's right lisa
real sub
another shameless plug
please subscribe guys
let's get back over 3 million right now
show us the power of the super trooper
soldiers 50 dollar super come on it's
still going down we're down
ethan you can do a markiplier and do a
smash or pass of every single pokemon
that can help the sub count
by the way i gotta say that idea i saw
that markiplier video he made that was
going like somewhat rare
so funny so genius i wish i thought of
that
smasher past every pokemon oh so good
come on guys the subs back up it's back
on the rise
oh i'm living in my basement this is all
i have
back up three million come on now come
on we need it get that expiring music
shout out to the families
rally the troops guys back at 808.
we're getting oh we're dead lost five
don't do that guys come on now we need
you this is all i have this is all we
dreamed of a b and love they stuck their
neck out for this they said listen we
know
we gotta cross that three three million
come on
show us something inspirational music
can uh listen
give us your best [ __ ]
cringe youtuber you know sub shout out
let's go let's hear it
what's up guys
yeah there you go they like synced up
perfectly yeah
come on we're we're going to do some
crazy [ __ ] man you guys got to subscribe
we're going to go to ukraine at 3am
what's going on we're gonna we're gonna
prank putin we're gonna do some wild
[ __ ] i need you to hit that like button
we need you to subscribe
if you just went down by one uh uh uh
i'm gonna call upon my european fellow
brothers and sisters come up pull up we
got we need three million we need 200
it's going up
all my european brothers and sisters
subscribe right now it's going up eu
gang rise up rise up sweden spain france
france whatever that country is
italy i know you guys are watching
subscribe there's gotta be at least you
know
poland
shout outs oh miss yeah
france anyone in france
lithuania pull up finland
even denmark sick we need we need 65
subs guys
60 subs
all right every other country that love
didn't mention
40 subs you guys this is we need our we
need our south american and north
american uh brothers and sisters two
subs we're about to pass it come on come
on ecuador guatemala congratulations
three million subscribers i can't
believe the second time today i've been
looking for it this is such a huge
benchmark for me i've been looking
forward to getting three million subs it
means a lot to have a podcast on this
platform with three million subscribers
you know just means so much guys thank
you for being here thank you for
subscribing we got 115 over 3 million
now i mean nothing could we will never
fall below 3 million again
we're turning this into a meme and it's
going to be a problem where we're just
going to hover right above and below we
just lost
we're back down we just lost
70. is it under 3 million don't stop dan
i'm asking no it's up it's going back up
okay play the inspirational music
guys guys come on
the least you could do is keep us above
3 million
how much do i do for you i come here
three four times a week
i am in quarantine and yet here i am
all that i ask is please to keep me
above 3 million it's all i need we're
supposed to be plugging for you well
you're not doing enough all right guys
listen we need you to subscribe okay
listen the ethan klein channel is doing
it's back down it's down to 41.
ethan is losing interest in the podcast
he's going to be it's bad we're about to
go under
if you guys don't subscribe it's down
it's below we just dropped below we
never even get back home he may be stuck
here oh people want that look at that he
left he's out
below 3 million again
we need
to save love subscribe
hit like button
dave live
yeah anyone else want to help me out
here
thank you guys for three million
subscribers delicious what a huge
milestone wow it's nice to be
appreciated and acknowledged did you
ever think when you started this podcast
that just we never had
three members
i never did isn't that crazy it's such a
huge number guys it's hard to even
imagine that's what they always go they
go yeah it's hard i can't believe it's
such a crazy number i can't even imagine
it
you guys it's all thanks to you guys you
guys made it happen here let's check it
now we're back below i'm out oh my god
okay
should i just ramble up european
countries
you already hit most of them didn't you
that's why we're trying to expand other
continents
guys it's such a huge milestone
i'm so stoked i never thought we'd get
here
i'm just so thankful wow
this is amazing let's just end above
three million because these clowns
yeah we're above 64 above
okay guys stop on subbing
stop it
okay no no it's not a joke don't play
the laughter
i'm serious it hurts when you guys do
that
okay all right we're 65 above right now
let's just end on a good note
thank you guys if you want something
you're not going to see our podcast
you want to see our pockets or you don't
want to see our podcast okay
it's that simple
if you're here watching subscribe
if you want to see it
subscribe
okay clearly you do you're watching it
right now let me check update
oh miss you i'm gonna make exclusive
behind-the-scenes content like exclusive
exclusive for people who haven't
subscribed for a certain amount of time
that's it sorry
can you do that yeah you can we'll talk
about it later
thank you i know how to do that really
yeah
anyone that subscribes right now i will
pay you
a hundred dollars
i just subscribe i just subscribed
i will give a hundred dollars to
everybody that subscribes right now
in minecraft in minecraft
i'll give 100 diamonds
what are the roblox uh bucks called
robux or something i'll give 100
niger i'll give 100
uh you just how about a hundred rupee uh
rubles that's just gonna say okay i will
give 100 rubles to every person that
subscribes right now 100 coconuts oh the
rube what is that worth right now ruble
i think it's pretty low the usd
to claim your money one dollar dm uh
suck this on that on twitter
yeah listen every everybody go home
get 10 family members to subscribe
that's breaking that stop that's
yo we need to promote to meet up getting
our [ __ ] channel banned
yo we need to do this thing where we beg
people
watch our channels you can get terminals
don't laugh it's not funny all right but
but on a serious note guys thank you so
much
thank you to love and abe it's nice that
you guys care we are above 3 million it
does it hurts i'll be honest it hurts to
see a dip so so you know
i don't even think it's actually that
bad because
what's weird about it is the views are
really healthy yeah the views are great
the channel's never been doing better
really yeah in terms of like views per
episode yeah so but then the sub count
declining simultaneously it's i've been
keeping an eye on it and it's honestly
baffling like
it's because we don't say it only i
think the real reason is because right
now we're really focused on keeping
everything niche and like in-house and i
think podcasts really grow when you're
bringing outside you're bringing
interviews true we don't have guests
and interesting stuff and that's when
you gain subscribers so i don't think
we're
gaining new subscribers i mean i don't
think we're i mean clearly we're not
really we are losing i mean we are
literally losing hemorrhaging
subscribers but i think that's
hemorrhaging but the views are it's been
it's been a trickle i would say more
than a half if you like it it's like hey
the people that like the show are loyal
you know you're loyal
you're good you're loyal you're smart
but uh i had i want to start we're going
to start having more guests soon so
maybe that will help with the sub count
jeff uh
maybe next week
just depending on
his reaction to this episode and uh have
we announced the other one and fresh and
fit maybe
but the other other one what was the
other one oh the girl yeah i don't know
who's talking to her people i am i just
don't know if you had publicly talked
about it yet so did you guys work it out
because i know we changed the date yes
it's happening yeah we can announce it
okay
we'll announce it what's your last name
i know her first name is drew oh uh uh
afuelo i think it's pronounced
let me i've only seen it spelled i
haven't heard it out loud so
yeah
our audience definitely knows her i've
seen her name the channel she's huge on
the big dog
she's super funny she's been blowing up
for
basically popping off on the same morons
like
fresh and fit
her name is drew
afuelo i hope i'm saying your last name
right can you typically
i went to her link tree and she doesn't
like her tick tock
which is probably where most you guys
know her from
um
i'm very excited
that she'll be joining us oh the chat's
blowing up yeah when is she joining us
uh not uh
not the coming friday but the one after
i believe um let me let me verify that i
put it on the calendar
when you close a video they keep playing
the sound it's like unbelievably
annoying like close it's still playing
the sound like what do i gotta do i
already closed it what do i gotta do
anyway drew afuelo if you don't know who
she is follower on tick tock she's super
funny and she's describe it as like oh
my god stop doing that to me tick tock
but uh i think it'll be a great episode
uh friday march 11th
is there someone else we were scheming
to get on the show uh
besides jeff and fresh and fit
maybe we got to try to get that cherry
the cherry or chloe cherry what's her
name
oh the girl from euphoria you guys were
talking about
and it's that she's a fan that's what
she told ian ryan
uh yeah yeah she she liked the show she
was very nice
very sweet and
turned in
so can someone try to reach out to her
sure maybe well olivia's not working
right now but one of you guys
for sure
all right well guys that's the show
thank you all
what a week it's been a great week
i'll be out of quarantine if i don't
have covert
uh by next week
anyway i hope you guys all have a
fantastic night again bless thanks for
me in here
all right see you next week guys
what you gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew goose and gaps
with all the guests you'll see the best
podcasts in the world take it from me jc
over chair hp baby we podcast now
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three
[Music]
on this
you